et la gagne on a un nouvel espace au
studio sfr dans laquelle on se trouve
présentement un tout nouveau studio fait
pour les conversations plus un tête à
tête dans un espace chaleureux
confortable on est bien ici ph on est on
vient d'enregistrer à peu près un
podcast pour notre pétrone d'à peu près
une heure et vingt ce qu'on fait jamais
parce que ben parce que l'on ne voulait
plus se lever on est trop confortable
c'est ça mais j'ai même pas vu le temps
passer en jazz et pis l'espace en fait
est en location dès maintenant donc si
vous aviez un projet de podcasts mais
vous trouviez que notre autre studio
était pas dans le format idéal pour vous
que vous vouliez plus du wan wan un
petit peu plus l'eau qui est un petit
peu plus qu'à jouer assis sur des divans
et bien maintenant nous le ferons donc
allé au studio sf point ca pour avoir
plus d'informations vous nous éclairer
et ça va me faire plaisir de louer pour
vous ce studio là qui vient comme
l'autre studio avec le matériel avec les
la technique le technicien nicole
parlons un peu des cas quand l'auto
journaux y ait des lots passe nickel
effet les fidèles au poste donc nicole
va vous aider si vous voulez partir
votre propre casse toi monsieur vous
avez un haut niveau studio sf point sur
une production du studio sfr
nous sans filtre le podcast on parle de
ce conte avec nos invités dates ci
dessus peuvent compter avec moi dôme
plante si vous voulez louer le studio
sfr temps l'espace cosy dans lequel on
est que l'espace studio sf traditionnels
que vous connaissez déjà si bien ça
vient avec le matériel ça vient avec les
techniciens ça vient avec la post
production puis vous avez 48 heures
après l'enregistrement dans votre boîte
courriel le podcast en faites ce que
vous voulez vous n'avez qu'a vous
concentrer sur votre contenu
elle est aussi dû à sa pointure pour
avoir plus d'informations à ce sujet là
sinon cette semaine grand plaisir
imprévu leur grand bonheur de recevoir
un auteur compositeur québécois que
j'admire énormément qui rend mes
préférés michael est la plus belle plus
je trouve qui est vraiment une voix
unique c'est patrice michaud 1go
tellement fort tellement tard à terre
tellement agréable notamment le fun
parlé avec lui un gain d'une grande
culture aussi un littéraire ça paraît
une terreur dans
les études antérieures qui connaît ses
classiques
on a parlé en fait de raconter sa vie de
sa vingtaine jusqu'à aujourd'hui qu'est
ce que s'est passé on a parlé beaucoup
de son processus d'écriture processus de
composition on parlait aussi de donjons
dragons mais patrice est un un joueur un
ancien joueur qui renoue avec et
merveilleux monde de donjons dragons
qu'on partage
alors ça vraiment y grimper dedans
savoir est ce que vous allez m'aider
conversation sans plus attendre on va
dire merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là grand plaisir est ce
que je fais pour mille et une raisons
puis c'était une très bonne raison de la
force pour ni vous rencontrez je t'ai
bonne intrigue et c'est celle à ses
pommes mon premier podcast auquel je
participe mais c'est le premier devant
devant les personnes
personnes puis il ya
rien qui est pareil à distance non y'a
rien qui paraît une bonne réunion il ya
point de rencontre de famille y'a pas
y'a pas un podcast une première
rencontre on se connaît pas nous autres
qui a le même la même portée quand on
l'a fait devant un écran d'ordi que
quand on est ensemble je contacte pour
le faire j'écoutais une coupe d'entrevue
qui te fait récemment justement pis dont
une au saguenay et puis les personnes
qui étaient entrevue à
présent demander mais pourquoi tu es
venu au saguenay nous voir qu'est ce qui
t'a dernièrement comme en septembre
combat j'aime souffert le taux peut
aller voir le monde la contribution à
personne dit il pas par un auditeur pour
tout et si c'était quelqu'un qui aime
sofala trild comme alela chacune
déplacera que faire des entrevues en
personne en contraignant pipe tu as fait
tousser à québec avec claude bernatchez
brillante le seul trottoir c'est un
drôle de contexte parce que puis je
pense que ça explique la la question où
l'intervention de la journaliste c'est
que aller jusqu'à récemment
les artistes ne faisait plus le tour des
médias pour
pour marquer la sortie de voir un
nouveau pour la promo en fait parce que
c'est pas tant la volonté de l'artiste
s'était aussi les médias qui ne
recevaient plus les invités à
l'intérieur de leurs murs qui ce qui
s'explique évidemment et puis moi
j'arrive 15 minutes après qu'on décide
ballon on recommence trouvait en fait
attention puis on se on se reçoit je
trouve surtout que ça tombe sous le sens
que ce soit moi qu'il l'a toujours fait
et c'est donc fait pour mille ans que je
fais ce métier là mais quand même ma
tournée des régions pour parler d'un
disque qui sort ou pour parler du
spectacle que je vais faire le soir même
à moins que j'aie vraiment pas le temps
je le fais parce que j'aime ce jeu ne
fait pas si c'était là purement pour de
la promo je me serais certainement
éclairer
au delà de tir ont souvent on revoit les
mêmes visages puis c'est probablement
quais des stations où je vais pas c'est
parce que j'ai eu moins de fonds aia ça
s'explique c'est humainement explicable
fait qu' une partie ta job qui est
apprécié il allait rencontrer le mondial
par les aléas wifi pas le cas de tout le
monde non non considérant 13 ans oui
c'est ça je veux dire moi ça me
ressemble j'ai toujours été un être
éminemment sociable et de josée rioux
s'est inscrit dans mon code génétique
depuis toujours j'aime interactions
j'aime la discussion j'aime rire j'aime
les autres car les impôts
ça se ressent pas ça se ressent joseph
coach sait juste qu'on se verrait opus
j'accepte tout aussi faut accepter le
fait que des gens même s'ils font un
métier qui les amène à la représentation
c'est faut accepter aussi des fois
qu'ils sont pas que c'est un commun
c'est comme un mal
obligatoire qui est qui qui vient avec
un métier de création
il y en a par contre aidées des artistes
qui
qui propose des trucs qui quittent se
dissocie pas partie stick mans mais qui
vont pas aller défendre personnellement
leurs propres oeuvres il ya des domaines
artistiques qui s'y prêtent plus bon la
musique la chanson qui denjean plutôt
populaire
si malheureusement remarquable quand la
personne est paré pour rendez vous pour
dire c'est pour pour présenter ce qui
est fait mais parfois c'est parce que l
époque l ai pas outillée betis exemple
pas des fois c'est aussi simple que ça
des chanteurs des chanteuses et auteur
compositeur interprète qui sont très
timides ou qui ont des sources des
choses close
c'est désolant les rentes et écrire
détourne qui tienne pour qui justement
la musique ses manières de s'exprimer
vraiment naturel mais la parole pas
vraiment oui mais
c'est drôle qu'on a longtemps et
qu'encore aujourd'hui on associe une
aisance à rencontrer les gens avec ce
métier là mais pourquoi ce serait le
coche ces deux affaires différentes
diamant quand tu prends les deux buts du
cancer mais on pourrait tous ont nommé
des artistes qui eux qui sont pas très
bon à aller défendre ou allez parler de
ce qu'ils font il faut respecter ça
aussi la question moi j'aime ce une
bonne une bonne piste de réflexion parce
que souvent on attend des choses de
d'artistes y en a au final peut-être que
cela retombe pas pantoute d'être la
sarthe ont peut-être même pas de faire
des tournées parce qu'au québec on veut
rencontrer mois ci c'est au québec qu'on
veut savoir qui on veut connaître la
cause derrière leurs rangs et puis moi
je suis promis à être comme ça tu sais
mais c'est culturellement dans la
consommation artistique au québec là les
gens le public ils veulent savoir thé
qui ils veulent connaître la personne
qui veulent arriver sur avec avec ce que
tu fais enfin que moi ça me sert bien
parce que j'ai toujours eu ce plaisir là
à
aller jaser de ce que je fais et c'est
remonter sur la genèse parler de ma
passion pour pour la chanson pour la
musique pour la littérature pour ça mais
c'est facile de le faire c'est james au
pire voilà ce qu'ont fait exacts
[Rires]
mais sur cinq ou six lycées beaucoup je
pense que là tîmone les monades
cité c'est quelque chose que je pense
que pour ben du monde c'est quand même
important de comprendre le contexte
raconter une histoire qui est une pièce
avec la proposition je trouve ce jeu je
me souviens d'avoir vu un kit fire un
spectacle puis je pense que tout ce
qu'on a eue c'était
bonsoir tout le monde puis remercie
beaucoup à la fin que je peux repartir
de là frustrés du tout c'était la manie
du sein c'est quoi la
c'est quoi qu'on t'offre c'est faux
sade et partage aussi la la comment ça
c'est dit c'est la formule 1 mais ils
savent avec la proposition artistique je
trouve c'est optimiser sur ces forces là
en fait lance ici justement tu es
quelqu'un qui est bon pour raconter une
histoire qui est habile avec les mots
betty lise l'ubs sinon mis sur la
musique c'est très attaché à la chanson
c'est de dalé comme
au pic at on est en spectacle on a la
chance de faire son ensemble c'est moi
je sors un disque eu
la dent ton short sur les courtes t'en
fais ce que tu veux tu comprends ce que
ce que ça t'inspire j'suis pas là je
suis prêt à tout et iphone moi j'appelle
un spectacle c'est l'occasion c'est ed
général arrêté jeudi sauf que c'est
c'est plus grand que nature quand on y
pense que là on il le sait vous êtes
dans s'agit là je vais pas me priver de
vous donner des clés ou de houe de
brouiller les pistes ou de ses neuf ou
de faire autre chose mais aussi richard
desjardins quand je cache découvre
durant ma jeune vingtaine quand je
découvre richard desjardins que j'écoute
que j'épluche et que je surprends
l'oeuvre de richard desjardins programme
un répertoire francophone si qui m'a le
plus touché c'est là que je comprends
aussi qu'entre les chansons et encore de
la place pour faire quoi pour faire de
l'art pour faire autre chose c'est
comment on va pas moi je n'avais pas
envie de me priver de ces moments puis
souvent ces moments là vont servir à
plein d'affaires mais souvent à aller
passer ouvrir la porte à une chanson qui
quand notre besoin une tonne qui plus
difficile vient juste de sortir que les
gens connaissent pour les re c'est comme
le seuil ça prépare
ça prépare la venue de ce qui va suivre
ça moi j'avais toujours fait puis je tu
arrives à ce métier là par la scène
ça je le dis parce que c'est un c'est
pas toujours le cot c'est ma génération
ceux avec qui j'arrive dans le métier
qu'ils sont de manière générale toujours
un peu plus jeune que moi quand j'ai moi
j'arrive à ce job là je vais avoir 30
ans premier album dans le trentin
premier album qui sort j'ai 30 ans fils
et puis les barrages il y avait 30 ans
ou six ans oui non mais on est
on s'écrit
[Rires]
pas trop
les statistiques avancées domaines
musique il s'était rendu à 30 ans si ça
fait longtemps qu'ils traitent ont un
fort appui que paul vi c'est vrai que
les bonnes chances 6 à la violence
allait être jamais mais je veux dire
après ça la balle est dans son camp
libre à toi de deux de faire mentir les
statistiques ou de te poser la fameuse
question pourquoi tu fais ça évidemment
on veut on veut que les gens nous
entende on veut que ça serait voir le
plus grand nombre de paires d'oreilles
de taille de coeur possible mais si à la
base c'était mon premier désir c'est
d'être connus et reconnus
c'est sûr que là ça sport avec deux
prises mais ça arrive que tu arrives sur
le tard puis j'en suis une dit un des
exemples mais quand j'arrive tout mes
contemporains mettons sont tous plus
jeune que moi dit je sens déjà que ya un
changement d'habitude il ya un
changement de donne un sens de chez les
jeunes créateurs il la plupart venaient
arriver avec des maquettes de thoune
c'était il y avait tous des aptitudes de
bidouilleurs
home studio bidouillage c'est tout le
monde arrive à quelque chose d'abouti
travailler il y avait eu la recherche et
développement en arrière ces
mots j'avais tout ça par contre moi
j'avais beaucoup joué devant du monde et
oui évidemment tu peux avoir les deux tu
l'avais fait commandant dé dans des bars
en tant que corps de musique originale
ou en tant que non ça c'est venu plus
tard moi mon premier amour de musique
c'était vraiment de jouer avec du monde
jouée avec des hommes ce
qui se rapproche le plus d'être dans une
équipe sportive ces jeux thermostat de
faire une activité avec des jobs dans
laquelle tout le monde trip bengale moi
c'était la musique enfin j'ai joué dans
les bars
j'aimais peu de temps
je te file hall je t'ai pas quelqu'un
qui était bien j'ai jamais été un
chansonnier de bang bang soit on
arrivait le plus les gens veulent qu'on
joue tel ou tel tournoi on disait on les
connaît pas
je me rappelle le montant maximum avec
qui c'est thomas
d'aquin caudal fond de la salle c'est
l'archétype du gua qui est un peu trop
chaud là
je sais pas qu'est ce qu'ils demandent
et
peut-être su gaston mandeville lecture
tout le respect que j'ai pour gaston
mandeville charge ou nous le jeune anton
menth chamakh ça me dit non il est
envoyé nous donne une bonne tonne de
gaston mandeville puis maxime amélie ou
sais que tu veux que je te lâche
et on était tout mais comme dit chico
l'on se penche ensuite magazines et des
volets quand même ce qui est menée chez
com
mais il ya quelque chose de peu importe
un peu la même situation
nous on joue à ce que ce qu'on écoutait
à l'épaule quand en 2002 moi j'écoutais
du dave matthews band j'écoutais du ben
harper puis j'écoutais on jouait d'eton
puis des groupes comme karkwa qui
commence et on peut se dire du tout
comme ça parce qu'on aimait sa part de
même aucune ambition un d'écrire mes
propres tourne entre qu'on sait c'est
venu très progressivement et puis
surtout aucune ambition d'en faire un
métier
jeu ça me ça me traverse pas l'esprit
pour moscou à la rigueur si je pensais
je voyais une un himalaya devant moi
nous y voyons donc je pourrais tu
faisais quoi part elle m'a jeté aux
études gouache moi j'ai fait des études
en littérature à l'université laval à
québec dans un programme entre autres
comment on a fait le même programme wit
est fait en littérature aussi au fait
que tu connais ton de conques
[Musique]
s'accroît moi j'ai fait les études
là-bas je trouve à québec en 2000 pour
commencer mon bac beaucoup de débouchés
au milieu
à cette époque lui à qui ce comme moi se
poser la question
oui ok je comprends pourquoi tu es la
côte ouest ces études là parce que tu
aimes ça moi j'étais j'étais vraiment
un littéraire je te prends un gros state
dans le sens où je te penches avait pas
d des notes à tout casser la
mais j'aimais beaucoup ce jeudi là
j'étais pas dans création j'étais
vraiment dans l'analyse littéraire
j'aimais ça puis mc est mené on dit mais
qu'est ce que tu oui peut-être peut-être
prof après ce que tu veux être prof moi
je sais pas trop qui est bon ça c'est
maintenant ça s'est réglé sinon ça
t'amène août 5e demain que moi je me
posais même posé cette question là
dessus moi j'allais à l'école j'ai bien
plus de mathématiques tel bonheur
c'est exactement mon choix
il se joint à dessus plus logique ben je
sais pas je pourrais être jeux
bibliothèque à st et le livre à lui
vraiment tout son sens quitter son
visage sans me regarder à fait je veux
biblio même si je m'apprête à passer ma
vie avec un biopic sur
la vie
la bibliothécaire de son école
[Rires]
mais même moi j'ai fait depuis ses pics
et same name questionner aussi et puis
là j'ai compris que je faisais pas ses
études en pensant à un métier je vais
ces études là parce que c'est ce que ce
que j'aimais je me suis dit bhv rottiers
qui avait bondi envers moi toute ma
vingtaine se résume à ces deux mots
envers avant de décider à qui je veux
que je vais essayer ça écrire des toons
faire des chauffeurs des concours faire
un premier album avant suscité comme
c'était pas clair latrell quitte ses
partenaires était clair c'est que
j'aimais la musique j'aimais la musique
mais comment tu aimais les mots de gérer
les mobiles bon évidemment je pense que
le ca deviens c'est clair que ces deux
traits parallèles qui ne l'étaient pas
puisqu'on finit par surgir
quand tu tripes sur la lecture sur les
souris sur les mots puis thème qui joue
de la musique pour les fans coincés en
zones il ya une zone qui se croisent un
moment donné ça c'était c'était la
chanson puis la chanson où on en était à
ce moment à l'autre et je vais rester
c'était fred fortin s'était c'était du
mort c'était coeur de pirate factice
était de la chanson
qui me parlait ici c'est un rapport à
l'apport pire ce qui se faisait
auparavant au québec il y avait main des
bonnes affaires qui se brossait ça
progressivement ça me donnait envie de
s'aimer moi j'ai longtemps douté de ma
place là dedans cpie du
cje commencé à écrire des textes c'était
bien mais est-il arrimage avec la
musique puis on perd moment donné
il faut accepter le fait aussi il ya un
deuil dans ce métier leur qui est dur à
faire mais mon dieu que ça fait du bien
une fois qu'ils aient fait je pense
qu'on peut extrapoler sur un paquet de
deux directions professionnelles
artistiques ou autres
c'est comment à l'année faute d'accès
de ne pas être aussi bons
que ceux que tu admires le plus
fou de lac-sergent jusqu'à ce qu'ils
restent
une petite pointe de tarte de
pourcentage en graphique qui est elle
demeure puis qu'il va cliquer elle
derrière qui va de driver pour dire oui
mais qu'en même temps je veux ce sont
meilleurs que sur je veux faire
différemment mais je
situe continuellement te dit voyons non
ainsi ça sera jamais aussi bon que
desjardins et non je parlais tantôt ça
sera jamais aussi banques
untel ou unetelle
ce titre a longtemps et c'est très casse
train aussi ses jeux d'hier faut
dépasser ça c'est super important puis
moi maintenant je me suis rendu là que
j'ai fait ok je vais arrêter de me
comparer et je vais faire
puis en verre ça dure six mois ça durera
site attendent des textes soient aussi
bob desjardins t'écris jamais c'est ici
on en parlait justement pas plus tard
qu'hier de ceux avec avec des deux
temples depuis 11 ans qui en est faux tu
vois jamais rien faire c'est attendre
demain au second supplément de ça pas de
bon sens ma fille tu te cache derrière
ce moment donné faut tout à l'admettre
ce une manière de
jeu j'y vais pas au dessus ça demande du
courage de faire ce dont ils ne me
posais la question d'y répondre non
c'est vrai je suis jamais j'écrirai
comme ça est ce que je dois faire autre
chose pour autant 20 le sont d'autres
paramètres en des signes ici ça rejoint
les personnes si tout le monde autour de
10 des der woodsen
d'autres questions mais passe passe par
dessus sur c'est tout le temps pour toi
aussi tu es peut-être jamais aussi bon
pour toi mais peut-être que pour
quelqu'un devrait être meilleur que ces
personnes là c'est la grande question du
juge de toi mais c'est important moi je
pense pas qu'il faut il exclure
complètement parce que sinon
c'est bon d'être dur envers soi même
c'est correct aussi de c il faut se fier
à à tout ton bagage culturel qui fait
qui tue et qui fait qu'est ce que tu
fais comme production artistique pierre
ton instinct aussi ses failles qu'il
faut être fois durs envers soi même mais
on va donner faut accepter aussi que
peut pas être seul juge de ce que tu
fais c'est super mal 5 puissamment
city aurait jamais dire jamais un autre
desjardins jamais un autre jean leloup
et j'aimerais un autre d'un mélange et
il y en a juste dit
qu'ils doivent d'avoir ce comme genre
d'idéal comme votre comme inspiration ça
peut te donner justement un espèce de
deux drive pour essayer de pousser plus
loin son truc mais
c'est la comparaison
ne pourra jamais être il n'y a pas une
recette qui est commun et daniel
bélanger c'est bon c'est l'enfer ce
marché pour lui ça marche propos pour
personne d'autre ici de trouver ces deux
tours y sont très actives la comparaison
c'est comme
c'est plus dans comment je peux faire
des quads aussi incarné puis d'aussi
fort que ce mais d'essayer de faire ça
marche chaleureuse la notion de la
recette support intéressant dans un
paquet de département parce que on
pourrait être très
idéaliste en disant que
c'est évidemment ça n'existe pas
vraiment ça n'existe pas et puis moi je
pense que quand un artiste veut faire
comme les autres où mène une vie
répétées qui est aussi à lui même c'est
déjà fait et qui a bien marché pour moi
le finder qu'on demande comment c'est
pour moi cela c'est le le lent début
leur le début rapide d'un déclin annoncé
fin mai en même temps quand on
s'intéresse un tant soit peu à la
musique pop on se rend compte que la
notion de recettes elle est super
importante ça jusqu'à juste se dire
juste admettre et constater que l'arcep
pop a changé c'est reconnaître
l'existence d'une ré sonne quand on
était jeunes
la musique papeete pas exactement ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui on le sait la
forme change et il ya des intervenants
majeurs retirer les fameux 3 4 comme
pour ceux
qui viennent des pays nordiques
politique empêche donc les toons
les leggings la question pourrait
pourrons-nous nous les nommés avec le
signe astrologique et la terreur moi
j'ai juste une intéresse en surface au
phénomène mais reste que la notion de
recettes est importante là il ya quand
même
des zones de basse
comme si tu moi je pense que si tu
t'inscris dans cette recette là
ça donne quand même des chances de
ça donne quand même une rampe d'accès
pour pour les médias mainstream de
musées comme quand les radios
commerciales par exemple ici le bois de
jugement de tchétchénie pour ni contre
je tourne sur ces radios leur
métier quand quand tu catch que ok je
vais m histoire le refrain ça existe
plus ou moins il me faut trois ou qu il
faut que le premier rock hill ramdin
premières secondes puis que martonas
dépasse pas 7 durée là bon la fameuse du
risque fait longtemps que ça existe mais
cessez de l'arcep veut dire qu'il ya pas
de recette c'est vrai qu'en même temps
c'est pas tout à fait vrai il faut
l'accepter
c'est ce qui est des paramètres dans
lesquelles est la chanson pop joue
droite epic games fois il ya des codes à
respecter métier c'est plus mettons
mettons patrice michaud mettons qu'il
met donc toi tapas et on ad'autant
l'adolescence jeunes adultes à écouter
du reggae depuis six mois je veux
chanter il fallait cette eau doit se
passer comme des fois il est des fois
faut vous trouvez c'est comme si quoi
ses forces et les forces de l'ordre
s'étaient pas les forces de l'ordre qui
étaient peut-être que tout dit
j'aimerais ça écrire comme richard
desjardins qui sera d'argent frais se
bouger comme elvis lancé georges en trop
et ça fait quoi
c'est un voeu pieux que tout les gens
qu'on admire aux autres vivent les mêmes
mots forts comme la fois où et couach
son nom et en
2008 peut-être 2007 ou 2008
je me suis inscrit par la porte d'en
arrière pour le festival en chanson de
petite-vallée là on était au moment où
je me couchais je commence à me
commettre s'est amusé et si j'allais
voir qu'est ce que les gens pensaient
tout seul et puis je suis je suis
sélectionné pour faire le festival une
conférence de presse à montréal j'arrive
et sur le trottoir ya michel rivard qui
disent qu'une avec nelson minville et sa
main ville qui travaillait pour le
festival à l'époque qui parolier qui
écrit beaucoup de chansons québec et
puis bon ben j'arrive je m'approche de
chirurgie de la vence comme je le disais
tantôt manche vient jamais de montréal à
chaque fois j'ai de quoi montréal pour
souvent chp a déjà à mort et attend
jared avance en cause dès qu'ils sont en
train de discuter et michel est en train
de dire à nelson que les poignées gunton
savoir pour qui pourtant il ya du bon là
dedans il le sait mais c'est comme si
les morceaux s'attachait pour les uns
avec les autres puis sait plus quoi
faire ni comme il est un peu à bout avec
ce projet tous là qui est pas capable de
domme de conclure je les écoute par
l'ugc phoques et michel rivard a dû
écrire
3684 chansons dans sa carrière pile à
l'huile il pas nier que les mêmes
problèmes que moi avec mes propres
tonnes et j'ai adoré ça sera je pense
que ça arrive souvent
plus plus on avance dans ce métier là
comme dans les autres ce qu encore ce
qu'on admire et ont souvent des
problèmes similaires aux nôtres qui se
posent encore des questions piece
episode c'est très sain ces quatre
albums plus tard trois gardes encore à
finir détourne de ses pires cadeaux
pourquoi c'est pire qu'avant su parce
qu'ils te plus de te plaît aux attentes
envers toi même août aux +2 et exigent
plus d'exigences je pense que de tout ça
et d'autres choses ouais ben si on quand
quand as tu déjà fait de quoi puisque tu
continues dans le même département ben
tu veux pas te répéter souvent en même
temps être intégré que les les gens les
gens te reconnaissent c'est pour moi le
cetc c'est aussi grave de repasser dans
même trail parce que on veut faire la
même affaire qui a marché que dire moi
je vois sonner un peu comme ce qui est
très trendy présentement ses jouets se
bat côté là dessus puis ces deux mots si
je veux je veux avoir une part de cette
enveloppe pour moi les deux les deux
directions sont malsaines
mais reste que quand quand années à
travailler mes concerts c'est un
quatrième disque ben tu veux
pas que tu veux mais tu essaies de
constater puis d'avoir l'esprit ouvert à
ce que tu es
présentement c'est artistiquement kss
kss kss qui bouillonne parce que en
trente et quarante ans
moi je suis convaincu d'avoir beaucoup
plus changé comme 20 et 30 ah ouais
ouais j'en suis intimement convaincu
nous toutes sortes de raisons le meti
amène à ce moment mon métier
se déroule sur cette période c'est
justement mon cet apport et 10 ans qui
est fait c'est oit être si je veux dire
c'est sûr que je commence à me planter
les pieds fin des années 2000 donc fin
de la vingtaine moi je suis les
décennies mais
si je gagne ce sera le grand bain en
2009 je reçois une bourse pour pouvoir
produire un premier album puis il sort
en 2011 chacun de milandre j'ai 30 ans
avec ça ce calcul assez vite c'est
durant cette période aussi que je
deviens père fait qu il ya énormément
d'enfants qui se passe pour moi dans ces
10 années là et mon rapport à la musique
change se développe mois 20 ans je suis
pas un mélomane du tout le à 30 ans non
plus quand même à 40 ans oui à 40 ans
oui j'ai mes goûts musicaux ont changé
mes envies de 2 comment comment je veux
faire de la musique ont changé avec
évidemment que tout seul je dis je pour
je peux pas faire le même disque à 40 4
4 ans et c'est impossible je ne suis
plus la même personne ça ça a commencé
dans le fait de hockey où je suis rendue
qu'est ce que je fais ça peut pas être
ça peut pas être plus facile je pense
que je suis plus exigeant aussi envers
moi-même
pour
je sais pas je sais pas pour quelle
raison mais si moi quand je suis allé
quand j'écris des tonnes d'abord c'est
jamais facile c'est toujours toujours
toujours un processus
pénible
que la tonne soit super rapide rôle
cakin waters c'est toujours dur en fait
plus elle est légère pire scénario ouais
plus elle est pas pire c'est c'est là
une chanson le comme souriante avec des
eaux khl pour moi c'est les plus et les
plus grands costauds parce que fo faut
pas que ça paraisse il faut que ce soit
bien fait comme comme le reste pisser
c'est plus exigeant c'est plus demande
je trie bloque tout le temps pour ça que
j'ai des projets bcd sur lequel je
travaille qui voit le jour où pau mais
qui m'empêche pas d'être sincère au lieu
d'ouvrir la tv d'écouté sports 30 demain
je vais d'autre chose faite la mécanique
demeure en action je penche pour
l'impression mais si c'est un métier où
on est très dur envers nous mêmes quand
on a le sentiment qu'on retient leur jeu
mais je m'appelle neudorf je vais je
fais rien mais oui tu fais rien parce
que t'es pas capable de sortir ce qui
est installée là tu vraiment très
exigeants psychologiquement ça amène des
fatigues à c'est surtout la période de
création évidemment le fait que non non
c'est pas je constate que c'est de plus
en plus difficile puis
bon ça se fait pareil puis après ça ben
on regarde ce qu'on a sous la main
qu'est-ce que je suis rendu au moins
avec tout ça c'est quand même toujours
un phénomène
une alchimie assez assez formidable
quand il termine diféo ça a été c'était
5 mai dernier - mais ce qui me prenaient
d'entrée dans le coeur puis puis bon le
dernier est particulier parce que je les
fais tu en gagnes je les faire dans le
bois en gaspésie pas d'électricité un
confinement total je les fait en formule
réduit en échangeant sur zoom pitt il
n'y a pas une
farce des derniers mois qui pore qui a
pas laissé son empreinte sur le disque
puisque use que je me plais à croire
quand les coupes on le sent pas les
traits de succès s'arrête là pour toi et
moi les parois que je les connais la
shac couture chez que toutes les voix
que j'ai fait dans le bois puis que j'ai
envoyée par passé par troyes juste mon
cellulaire page avait pas internet puis
que c'est la voix qu'on entend chanter
dans un micro exactement comme celui là
dans une petite carte de son dans mon
laptop pendant que les chevreuils mais
pas d'en face
mais c'est sûr que peut-être qu'on
n'entend pas ces choses là mais c'est
sûr que sa tante l'oeuvre c'est sur ces
sources oui ce serait d'une tristesse de
passer le condamne à
décrire quelle heure il est vrai qu'ils
passent puis que c'est stérilisés
évidemment je suis quelqu'un ça revient
ce qu'on disait tantôt jeudi c'était
dans ton char tu t'écoutes la grande
évasion tu ne sais pas que j'ai chanté
sont dans les bois devant les chevreuils
mais après ça c'est la beauté de la
chose
je ne sais pas jusqu'à quel point on
peut faire ça avec la musique
électronique ou le black metal norvégien
mais la chanson sa prestation on nous
parle la jeunesse de comment j'ai écrit
ça puis après ça ben
ça ma serre dans ta tête et cou depuis
les tourner la même manière moi je m'en
sers beaucoup un spectacle de ses impôts
systématiquement la prochaine chanson
sabol n'ont
jamais
[Rires]
été malade pendant deux sets
cet exercice d'écrire à chaque jour
pendant un an
puis c'est une nouveau notre processus
de genre d'avoir cette routine de je
m'assois puis j'ai peu importe qu'ils
soient nouveaux ou est ce que je vais
leur faire je pense que oui mais c'est
pas devenue une
c'est pas devenu quelque chose de
systématique c'est vraiment j'avais en
tête d'affiché les cocotiers ou a
toujours eu de l'admiration pour les
gens qui écrivaient soit quotidiennement
ou de manière très régulière c'est
souvent des auteurs hommes femmes issues
de la littérature
c'est moi j'ai mangé un rapport
amour-haine beaucoup plus d'amour que de
haine mais avec stephen king que j'aime
beaucoup j'aime beaucoup le bonhomme
puis
il ya beaucoup écrit sur son rapport à
l'écriture sur sur ses années de
jeunesse sont al que son alcoolisme ces
jeux d'hier et délivre écrivait il
faisait tellement cool qu'il saignait du
nez sur sa machine à écrire puis c'est
un gars qui écrivait régulièrement de
manière parfois comme maladie venue ou
plus près de nous et de manière quand
même pas mal - work je sais que jacques
poulin romancier québécois écrivait
aussi de manière très régulière plus je
pense que c'est autant de points qui va
vérifier ne lui fait pas en fait
les chansons que oui enfin de laisser un
commentaire
on sait qu'il est un grand total
100g qu'écrivait deux boucles j'avais
entendu pas les écrivais deux bouts
purin rétractile ses actes il ya quelque
chose les restes humains stallone
hygiène de vie dans qui relié intimement
reliée à ton métier puis pour ses
auteurs l'appui pour ben des domaines
artistiques ton métier ta vie c'est
difficile de tracer la frontière moi je
voulais essayer ça mais c'est sûr que ça
va m'amener dans des hommes d'écriture
que je connais pas si je me suis me suis
donné des des règles à suivre
évidemment si une journée où j'écris
peau c'est pas la fin du monde par
contre je devais la reprendre avec un
système de date en fait tous aussi
simple que ça et c'est pas parce que
j'écris une journée que cette journée
leur compte dans le sens où si sir pas
si j'ai pas comme identifié la pièce du
jour c'est le morceau parce que c'est un
peu n'importe quoi ça fait des courtes
phrases des voice
des cours porté de la prose aussi plus
rarement la poésie en prose oui
absolument
si si si je regarde se faisaient bien
c'est correct mais il n'y a pas de
perdre mais pas de perles il n'y a pas
de rien qui brille là dedans y aurait là
dedans qu'il peut transformer à qui je
ne suis pas satisfait
cette journée est à reprendre aussi
ouais ouais c'est combien d'heures par
jour peu importe je pouvais avoir un
flash un super beau flash fait que je
vais l'écrire ça en 32 minutes puis ma
journée est faible où je pouvais aussi
me permettre dans une journée si
j'écrivais beaucoup d'identifier plus
qu'un beau morceau puis là je regagnais
des journées reste qu en octobre
novembre décembre de cette année là ça a
été vraiment j'avais bain des journées
de report à reprendre puis kutch pas là
pour flasher le il ya personne qui est
au courant que je fais c'est à ce moment
là je suis le seul juge fait que y'a pas
je vois pas tricher avec moi-même
troisième le botter le cul et ça m'a
amené à écrire beaucoup
et à juste mappy quand on écrit beaucoup
et surtout quand on écrit jean à des
heures irrégulières ou sont ainsi pas
habituellement et pire mieux encore
quand tu écris à un moment où trop envie
de phase il ya de bonnes chances que ça
produisent quelque chose d'inusité de ce
repreneur le saint ouen deux à
l'extérieur de thé comment dire de temps
des cadres qu'on se fixe sans le vouloir
doter les fondamentaux madani moi je le
vois le
sait je pense que les gens qui me disent
on ça ça fait vraiment c'est vraiment
une tonne comme une tonne de patrice
michaud sucer c'est mes fondamentaux qui
sont les vôtres si moi j'étais un peu
poignet avec ça je fais partie de ceux
qui écrivent tout le temps sur les mêmes
personnages si j'ai accepté ce sens
notre deuil que j'ai eu à faire c'est
accepter le fait que sur tous mes albums
j'ai au moins une tonne
qui est la déclinaison d'une tonne que
j'ai déjà écrit pas d'un arrêt de deux
personnages écoute je ce que ce soit en
mode
plus appuyé ou en mode vraiment dans le
tempo dépressif il ya plein de tunes qui
parle de ces deux entités la
qui s'aiment mais qu'ils se reposent en
même temps qu'ils sont justes dans
l'incapacité d'être ensemble puis de
constater l'échec qui qui vivent même si
c'est
même si encore un sentiment amoureux là
dedans je ne sais pas quand j'écris
stupide accompagne
toutes les nommer ou à peu près sûrs
chacun des disques surtout à partir du
moment où j'ai accepté que j'en ai pas
fini avec les autres dit ça ça vient
aussi de lecture rouge qui ont ce
phénomène là est remarquable chez
d'autres auteurs c'est un projet sans
musique en littérature tout seul et
j'ai travaillé beaucoup sur l'auteur
georges perec h à l'université en fait
le mon mémoire de maîtrise que j'ai
commencé et qui n'est pas entendue
c'est justement un auteur qui repasse
continuellement sur les mêmes séquences
de sa vie les mêmes thématiques pas tout
le temps métier il ya vraiment
ça va jusqu'à ce qu'apple
intertextualité tu te rappelles l'option
moi ça me parlait beaucoup l'otiv la
pénétration de l'univers fictionnel soit
d'un d'un tiers ou de ce que tu as déjà
écrit à travers ton oeuvre moi j'aime ça
je me dis sans faire du
procès le fun que ça traverse un univers
de chansons aussi c'est un personnage
qui revient
cinq son album concept l'examen n'a pas
annoncé jeudi un grand voyage est
organisé c'est ce que j'ai fait le plus
proche d'un album concept j'ai jamais eu
goty de le dire parce que
total à moitié du monde en salle qui
s'en vont en courant et pourtant moi je
pense que nous donne encore cinq ans la
grosse mode album concept album est mort
vive la banque est-ce que ce que tu
disais le par rapport à
l'intertextualité dans l'oeuvre d'un
auteur c'est vraiment le fun pour
la personne qui sait la clé par elle
même et on invente de ta musique qui te
suivent pellerin que l'impression de
suivre ces gens le type qui comprend un
peu dans les références et je dire on
est une encyclopédie commune qui se
construit puis mon étudiant rémois jeu
là je la vois la touriste je vois les
coûts de la clé deux heures ouais puis
faut que tout se défend évidemment il
faut que tout se défendre sans ces
mécanismes alors il faut que quelqu'un
qui arrive je te lire il faut que tu
puisses que consommer l'oeuvre en tant
que
place value on dirait pour quelqu'un qui
voit pas dans l'univers et puis c'est
faire confiance en
en oeuvre dors chez toi tu tobo en
construire des couches de sens là il y
en a qui vont quatre chasseurs il y en a
qui ont pas besoin de quatre chasseurs
puis à bain d affaires il ya une
déconnexion qui vont se faire malgré toi
évidemment que tom même pas vu que qui
sont même pas prémédité c'est ce qui est
beau le cd lieu commun le métier la
fameuse phrase tu le comprends comme
tout joueur puis c'est ça ta partie puis
mais reste que c'est vrai il ya des gens
pour qui une chanson un film une photo
ça va évoquer quelque chose qui vient de
leur paysage un motif puis c'est tout là
tout l'intérêt pour moi de l'oeuvre
d'art est là et d'arrêt dans la
ce que ça produit comme effet c'est que
c'est comme comme comme émotion quand
même
voilà surtout des textes sont son spread
bien justement être interprétée un peu
de la manière dont le virus quand même
s'abstrait en général c'est très ouvert
oui c'est pas très premier degré nancy
s'est fait que ça arrive ce métier que
tu arrives à étapes avec une
interprétation du tout un fan qui
viennent dire que finalement c'est comme
acquis moi mon attention c'est pas du
tout ça mais cool que tullaye catchy
oui tout est arrivé peut arriver des
gens qui venaient en europe et qui me
disait moi cette chanson là qui parle de
soja
qu'école parfait je sais je sais puis il
n'y a pas de ya pas de bol
non c'est sûr mais c'est déjà arrivé
puis l'inversé déjà arrivé aussi qu'on
vient de me voir puis comme dit c'est
comme sur la dernière le dernier album
chansons
où j'étais hanté par une phrase
pitié
je pas sûr encore de savoir exactement
ce que je faisais avec ça mais ce que je
sais c'est que c'était vraiment beau
fixe à ahl el yamani je sais ça vole
j'assume le fait que c'est pas clair
très évocateur jacques rossât après
quelqu'un qui vient boire c'est vraiment
un think thank you
say say say les deux personnages dont je
parlais tantôt le qui sont constamment
en train de se rejoindre puis 2 2 ce qui
tu es et puis l'entité gorce a aucune
importance
un des deux
se retrouvent devant une machine à tous
puis il met de l'argent dans machine à
tout parce que il veut pas nier la
poupée qui ressent a en tout cas moi
j'étais obnubilé par la machine a tout
oublié sur qui je trouve ça c'est une
machine à toutous dans le coin d'un dans
un vieux centre commercial ou un salon
de quilles walrus d'une tristesse inouïe
c'est la vieille patente avec les vieux
jouets dont personne à personne on veut
quelqu'un qui me questionner là-dessus
pitié je voulais te faire jeudi coach
sait je sais pas ce que je voulais
mettre la troupe à savoir au pot limit
roussat bondoux s'autorise tout son or
fait que c'était suffisamment avec toi
oui évidemment que il ya eu
depuis 2005 ornementations par exemple
le 2 mai 14 mais creusent la terre
seraient trouvés les anglais l'ont
j'avais les ondes et courtes tollé les
mollets littérale n'aura pas la nuit
depuis web qu'est ce qui vous faisait
ouais c'était celle-là tu vois ça c'est
un bon exemple
rien dans j'aime bien
j'ai le surréalisme le plus sous-estimé
je pense qu'avec moi je j'ai tout le
monde pense que je sais je trouve qu'il
ya une coupe de l'aude d'acide dans ce
que j'écris puis la beac et ses livres
et apparaît plus bas il ya probablement
un peu d'être
puis jeudi seul je peux je suis en train
de dire à heroes 1 vous avez raté je ne
comprenais pas ce n'est pas mon génie
mais des fois oui c'est très souterrain
pour moi je me rappelle c'est que
j'avais j'ai déjà eu longtemps un projet
de chanson qui s'appelait ondes courtes
sur
le narrateur et c'était vraiment des
appels à la haine de l'autre la machine
ondes courtes c'était là la métaphore de
quelqu'un qui a besoin d'être qui
lancent des appels qui qui qui reçoit
personne n'y a pas de ya pas de réponse
je me rappelle avoir traîné cette phrase
lancée ou des phrases avec avec
l'expression on court tous les maux en
cours de danse j'ai traîné ça pendant
des années kimoce c'est mon métier
soberanes ziti si j'écris pour tous les
jours pendant 365 jours parce que ça
arrivera pas que ça le deviendra pas
régulier je suis quand même quelqu'un
qui accumulent de l'écrit en pièces
détachées sur de très longues périodes
et souvent une toune va être constituée
de toutes sortes de morceaux moi je suis
là pour pas que ça paraisse pis pour
pour que les futurs tiennent bon mais
reste qu' il y avait des tonnes avec des
phrases qui les précèdent dont la
création et précède la tonne de quelques
années puis france le titre à la
victoire dans sa carrière seulement le
feu de chaque jour sur le deuxième album
j'avais ça dans un calepin de mais je
travaille au montant qu un peu courte
mais belle
époque où c'était là c'est puis je fais
pression mise à mal amalgame se fait
dans le processus mais j'ai encore je
traîne encore des vieux documents je me
dirai peut-être encore deux trois bonnes
phrases là donc j'ai pas utilisé puis
l'idée des ondes courtes cerné de la
fait que le cll que les hommes ils ont
pu lui qui quittant dans une quête
perpète l'amoureuse tout tout est là
pour ne pas qu'ils se rejoignent c'est
puis en plus il ya un fleuve entre les
deux temps tout les sépare bon c'est un
peu allant
piraterie penser de ces d'espérer que
98% des gens qui ont écouté la chanson
mécanique générale ont pas compris ça
pique ça les saleuses a pas dérangé de
les a pas dérangé deux seront servis
dites moi mécanique générale quand c'est
sorti certains carnet
mécanique générale de l'album soit en
2014 parce que l'album sort en même
temps que ma fille avec la toune sort
quelques mois à 20 je dirais novembre
2013 cas commencent à tourner à ce
moment là je suis
je travaillerai fait presque 10 une
maison d'édition vient il s'appelle les
étions pas si simple j'ai écrit des
contes pour enfants sérieux - je
connaissais pas que ça finisse yen vis
doigts de tous puis c'était des comptes
en fait pour l'apprentissage de la
lecture fait c'étaient des grosses
trousses puis j'écrivais sans histoire
avec des degrés différents j'avais une
fiche pour les différents degrés là j'ai
tout ça mais qui est bain puis il ya une
des histoires plus peut-être quelqu'un
qui va écouter ce que ces enfants ont
ramené sur l'homme il ya une histoire ça
s'appelle la mécanique du coeur puis qui
sait quand j'avais entendu mécanique
générale c'était comme cette idée là qui
m'était propre et qui avait un geek
export qui avait un genre de garage mais
c'est un garage ou est ce que kant avait
le coeur brisé talent est là
mais l'idée était venu vraiment de
tables tournantes toi je me rappelle
j'ai entendu tout à fait
j'avais comme extrapoler un peu là
dessus puis il ya un texte qui existe là
je me rappelle plus dans quel trousses
dans quel boîtier de lecture mais un
texte qui existe qui a inspiré
directement de de mécanique générale
ça me fait vraiment plaisir d'entendre
ça parce que moi le jeu
je crois pas que
l'idée quasiment divine de l'inspiration
prix de l'originalité ça fait peur aux
enfants
où on est tous des produits on est tous
des produits du mil des milieux du
milieu culturel familial né mais dans
lequel on a poussé puis compose encore
et quand on crée quelque chose on le
fait aussi à partir de tout ce qui nous
a culturellement constituer un bon c'est
un peu alambiqué aussi comme formulation
tout ça pour dire que on est toutes des
recycleurs ont un taux d'erreur cyclope
après ça on en refait briques bien ou
moins bien mais on s'est toujours à
partir de de ce qu on va ramasser
d'autres choses thé et il ya une belle
image de soi que la nomme souvent parce
que ça ça mérite d'être clair réjean
ducharme auteurs que j'ai beaucoup lui
aussi faisait aussi des oeuvres d'art
visuel qui appelait les trop fou si je
me trompe pas
c'est des sculptures faites à partir de
cochonneries qui rend manset dans les
rues et ruelles de montréal tient tous
des affaires où des morceaux d'amphores
qui ont déjà servi à quelque chose ou
qui servait encore et lui utiliser ça
pour ça illustre bien aussi son rapport
au langage que j'entends m'était très
très puisé beaucoup dans leur réalité
dans le langage parlé détourner le sens
des mots aller chercher des mots des
mots il vraiment issu du langage
populaire fait qd il sert de tout ce qui
est autour de toi pour fabriquer quelque
chose moi je fais toujours sur une plus
les années passent plus je marque le
coup plus je le surligne plus je fais
des emprunts avouer
que j'en de change les fêtes il ya une
phrase dans la chanson kamikazes il ya
une phrase qui est la pierre angulaire
de toute la zone qui est une phrase de
réjean ducharme que je découvre dans un
recueil de poésie de maxime qu'atelier
que j'ai croisés à rimouski parce que y
écrivait des d'amour afin de sonder à ma
blonde de l'époque qui est encore ma
blonde aujourd'hui j'aime ça - petite
brosse et sa maxime que je salue
d'ailleurs qui avec qui conversent
occasionnellement mais puis plus plus ça
avance plus je plus je le signale sur
mon dernier album
[Musique]
j'ai écrit une tonne qui s'appelle un
coeur de baleine bleue c'est une
paraphrase d'un
roman de jacques poulin dont on parle
est un tout qui s'appelait le coeur de
la baleine bleue je le fais beaucoup sur
lui même musicalement j'aime se le faire
piquer des fois c'est pas toujours
obligé de le signer mais
j'aime ça faire des emprunts des
hommages à aller à des toons connu à des
artistes connus train toutes les
exemples musicalement il nous faudra
venir voir le show mon dernier show mais
on a vraiment retravailler une vieille
tonnes à moi une tonne qui sont mon
deuxième album rien de violent de mettre
une tonne justement de 2014 qu'on
voulait dont on voulait vraiment changer
les arrangements puis depuis une coupe
d'un mois je découvre le bruce
springsteen des années 80 je connais mon
relie springsteen puis j'ai découvert
springsteen avec ses albums des années 2
20 90
le vieux springsteen mathon chaque heure
je suis comme tomber dans bonnie glacé
puis on écoute ça que mon goût capote
berom ont fait une tonne sur le sur le
nouveau spectacle s'appelle jusqu'à ce
que je tombe qui
vraiment
dommage complet et total
dans ses mines au dock de sur blue
springs et c'est le même début c'est le
même genre de
keyboard évidemment maintenant on rentre
dans ma toune fekter merci ça je le fais
beaucoup dans les textes je le fais
encore plus du grand détour pour dire
que moi je trouve que c'est un
trou ce fascinant de faire ce travail-là
de le voir chez les gens c'est qu'est-ce
que
quelles oeuvres d'art qu'est l'auteur
quel film qu'elle tonnes doit amener à
tous à partir dans une direction puis
produire autre chose je veux dire c'est
probablement 90 95 % de l'histoire à
part une coupe de coups de génie
unis cité qui existe c'est une grosse
part de la culture populaire c'est notre
fils passe bien souvent qu'un candidat
et ça c'est vraiment original je
m'attends de s'avancer jusqu'à ce qu'on
n'a pas référencé
d'inventer quelque chose à musique c'est
surtout maintenant je m'étonne et années
68 ans je devrais y était il y avait un
terrain de jeu immense il y avait d'une
nouvelle technologie puis aller d'une
nouvelle façon de produire la musique
physique il faisait des trucs quitterai
jamais entendus assure et puis
aujourd'hui n'est qu'un bon là les
puristes les puristes de devenir musique
afro américaine des années 40-50
pourrait pour à les déboulonner la plus
empruntée où j'ai pas envie qu'on
embarque là dedans mais oui questionner
la notion d'originalité mais je pense
pas qu'il faille tôt c'est le terme
c'est je pense qu'encore des affaires
très surprenante c'est jeudi la perfo de
hubert à tout le monde à lexington
traîne aussi
bon c'est une démarche très original est
ce qui est inventé le noise non mais
mais il y avait pris le nom est il le
mit
démarche originale
c'est malgré sa
personne il ya personne qui ne s'inscrit
pas dans une continuité artistique très
puis c'est fascinant parce que c'est ça
l'identité d'un artiste
tu viens d'où comment tu commentes au
tableau c'est ça puycasquier riquet que
c'est devenu quoi world pointe moi je
serai là dessus mais en or si justement
une barbe de quelques semaines pour
parler de type mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui justement en musique est
tellement de choses qui ont été faits
que l'original tv m'inclus dedans
qu'est-ce que tu mélanges c'est
quelqu'un qu'elle melting-pot d'
influence tu vas chercher pour au moins
faire un métissage qui seule lui est
nouveau c'est maintenant absolument moi
j'écoute j'étais en train de développer
malheureusement j'étais en train de
développer le même genre de de maladie
que j'avais durant mon bac si c'est le
cas ça nous guette tous quand on est aux
études en littérature on peut seulement
mais un moment donné tu es c'est
difficile de lire en tassant l'étudiant
on lit de quoi qu'ils en aient tout en
train un peu dans l'analyse s'est
repositionnée dans le temps ça c'est
décortique la faire tout ce qui était
plus dans le plaisir pur de lire moi ça
va faire peur un moment donné
j'avoue qu'en musique j'ai développé un
peu le même problème
j'écoute beaucoup de musique je
m'intéresse à plus d' affaire qu'avant
mais il ya toujours
le channel qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui
m'intéresse la danse
comment ça a été fait c'est quoi les
faits qui est leur puis comment ça se
fait que le snarr sonne au temps puis
c'est toujours à homme
ce correct des formations
professionnelles j'imagine ce qui fait
que moi quand j'écoute des taux jeudi
des listes le maintenant en musique je
travaille deux cases m'apparaît comme à
l'écrit c'est à dire que j'ai des
playlists très longue de tourner que je
conserve pour différentes raisons que ça
ait de la veille général à
ckoi lé c'est quoi la plaie de quel
genre de plaintes de riverains utilisent
à deux minutes de l'endroit de saint puy
écrire
tout et tout est licite et je n'ai pas
ramené je ne sais plus je suis rendu
puisque août une tonne comment ça se
fait qu'elle est que ce que j'aimais là
dedans c'est est-ce que
souvent m'étonne musicalement pipi jeu
musicalement je trouve que méthodes sont
meilleures avec les années mais c'est
aussi parce que j'ai vraiment ouvert
mais mais mon horizon musical puis
j'écoute plus d'affaires puis je brasse
plus d'affaires puisse correct la marge
moi je ça deviendra jamais
du bar le nord dans le sens du jeu c'est
je peux pitch est
quand même pas mal à gauche parce que
naturellement est quelque chose qui me
ramène un peu vers mes fondamentaux dont
je parlais tantôt puis ma zone - a lille
la finale et là le coup de golf plus le
vin ça m'amène à temps et s'améliore et
puis maintenant que je le sais je triche
on touche fraîche à gauche je lançais
plus beaucoup plus qu'avant oui parce
que ça finira pas de même c'est savoir
parce que je ne tourne qui fait
cinq minutes 50 sur mon dernier album
que ça devient prog non j'ai quand même
une toile à 5906 est un bon juste milieu
qui est un bon
on quand on compare les attentes au de
desjardins et puis après ceux de de
l'emploi mais tarbes une anecdote je me
rappelle j'ai eu la chance que ma mère
m'aime me fasse écouter dur desjardins
beaucoup puis je me rappelle la chanson
les yankees m'avait vraiment marqué qui
il ya une phrase dans les yankees cela
dit nous avons traversé des continents
des océans sans fin et sur des rats
d'autres essais de rêve puis je me
rappelle je lisais amos daragon
l'apéro qu'acheter manqué d'amour je
tombe dans le 3ème 4ème tome je tombe
sur cette phrase là oui mot pour mot le
fleuve a été un mois j'étais jeune ouais
si le jeu va voir mais s'il a reconnu je
reconnais cette phrase heures parce
qu'on l'a chanté à tue-tête dans le
champ par contre on allait au chalet
pile je revends la magie montre la
phrase à la regarde
l'a dit on va aller demander finalement
d'aller au salon du livre quand qui est
revenue avec son livre georges c'est moi
qui est allé le vosgien
se bouffe on le sait à tous et bien
payer ce prix me regarder à faire les
prises a failli pas très grave il m'a
regardé bien qu en fait oui george un
hommage à la terre un hommage qu'il faut
que tu connaisses petit tour des idées
les lecteurs d'amos daragon qui avait
déjà entendu cette phrase là que ça
rappelle ne pas en avoir tant que c'est
passé comme moi et c'était faut que tu
saches mais tu le sais moi je trouve ça
correct mais ça faisait comme je me
sentais comme fier de mon cou je pense
que quand c'est aussi mots pour nous
repousser sur une phrase emblématique
d'une trace d'une tour emblématique d'un
artiste il n'a pas eu le milan lui
apprécié de la 40e à ses actifs comme
le dit pas comme c'était pour moi ça n'a
rien à voir avec avec du plagiat même si
c'est pas mais je suppose et souvent ces
questions l'autre sein d'un même manière
que quand quand j'ai emprunté une tonne
et une tonne une phrase de réjean
ducharme pour mettre dans ma chanson
j'étais quand même pas à l'aise avec le
fait de la laisser là de dire oui c'est
les soldes c'est une phrase de réjean
ducharme fake moi j'ai fait là j'en
avais tellement besoin de cette phrase
c'était tellement la phrase qui allaient
là
que j'ai j'ai appelé ma maison disent tu
fais ton faut qu'on puisse
demandez à permission à réjean de chat
je sais c'est qu'ils réjean ducharme à
ce moment là c'est l'auteur fantômes qui
berne qu'on n'a jamais vue depuis 50 ans
qui se présente nulle part et qui à ce
moment là avait dépassé 80 si jamais tu
es décédé déjà qui était son père ça
qu'on envoie un long thier j'évalue mes
chances à 0,01 pour samedi et on le fait
par et pendant ce temps le mojo à écrire
des versions bcd de france qui pour
aller là bas qu'on envoie la demande à
aux éditions gallimard fait que ça doit
sa forme à montréal mais ça sera
quand paris
puis ils nous disent mais regardez puis
on pioncer on s'informe voici le cas de
figure
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'on devrait
faire très plaisir disait ben nous on
croit que vous devriez demander la
permission à l'auteur fait qu'on va
cheminer la demande mettez moi en
contact me tourner on va mener leur ai
dit mettez moi en contact pour ceux qui
connaissent la nature de l'homme puis
faites moi je fais à ce moment je suis
ok mon chien est mort fait que voici
michaud cris des cris d'autres afghans
navel tout tout moins bonnes évidemment
axel les fans predica détaché six mois
est remplaçable mais quand ils sont au
bout d'une courbe de moore ont reçu un
courrier disant vous avez l'autorisation
de l'auteur d'utiliser la phrase je sais
ça ça veut dire que yann réjean ducharme
d'une manière ou d'une autre comme il
peut avoir dit haut et fort qu faire mon
footing ou bien dans les maillots c'est
de regarder le texte de la trogne ferme
on le saura jamais vraiment quelques
mois après c'est sûr les textes il y
avait là tous n'étaient pas enregistrés
juste jeu ses paroles je sais pas
incroyable j'avais écrit un petit mot ou
si
j'avais
je parlais de m quand même très succinct
mais de mon rapport à son oeuvre du fait
que j'ai été accompagné dans son oeuvre
par marie-andrée beaudoin qui était ma
professeur de littérature à l'inversé la
vache est présent seul lavaur d'être
retraités marie-andrée à madame brouette
qui était extraordinaire
bon petit jeu les nommer aussi j'avoue
je plaçais mes billes pas c'est quand
même la dernière conjointe de gaston
miron
comme tout
peut-être pas robert charlebois mais
j'aimerais
écrit pour le body tout numérique c'est
sûr on
[Musique]
parlais tantôt de
tous les artistes sont à l'aise
justement à faire la tournée des
entrevues il ya c'est l'exemple
tellement qu'il est question des
théories du complot que oui c'était sa
femme qui faisait les textes outre
81,66
ya rien qui a pas été dit avec la marée
d aval il je me rappelle pas de détails
mais il était quand même en lice pour le
goncourt le prix je pense qu'avec la
vallée de la volaille a gagné le le prix
premier roman dans le contexte du
goncourt hockey fait date dans l'espèce
de
compétition lorsqu'elle goncourt et les
ja comme gagner le premier a manqué la
première fois que ça arrive de québécois
bons essais seront tous ce contexte là
on m'a aidéà comme à réduire la tempête
je sais que il ya une rumeur qui dit que
c'était naïm kattan qui écrivait sous un
pseudonyme il ya une rumeur il ya une
rumeur qui disait que c'était
voyons c'est un contemporain de peu plus
vu que georges perec mais il faisait
partie de l'oulipo aussi l'instinct un
auteur qui
c'est lui qui écrit les cent mille
milliards de poèmes
dans le recueil de poésie à chaque
chaque vers le livret grandes mains
chaque chaque verre peut se mettre à dos
les papiers tranché fake la combinaison
de toutes les sonnets l'alexandrin qui
sont le donner cent mille milliards de
combinaisons possibles c'est plus les
gens ils sont il essaie de m'aider le
clic est votre commentaire
raymond queneau merci beaucoup michaud
il ya même eu des rumeurs qui disaient
que c'était vraiment qu'un outil qui
déjà fait à partir l'académie française
c'est un long tard jeudi a connu et
reconnu le fait que tout sauf un jeune
club de 20 en cinq ans peut écrire une
oeuvre qui bon vu que il sait avoir
nulle part mais c'est ça c'est c'est
quand même assez un fameux
d'avoir pu
utiliser une région de chambre qui pour
lui mais c'est ça pour moi c'est
important et je sais que dans les années
à venir je veux être dans le même mind
inpi la même mécanique c'est de plus en
plus j'ai envie de le montrer
c'est quand on écrit ça raconte
qui tu es mais d'où tu viens du projet
c'est un cap chat en gaspésie à 15 ans à
l'abri si tous ces gens là tous ces
films là tous et toutes ces musiques là
que steam tu veux que ce soit petite
fille lisa prend finalement la
différence de l'emprunt plage et si
situe la somme ne sais pas si c'est
comme ça présentant les nazis c'est
comme comme bryan perro c'est comme lui
faire un
clin d'oeil oui c'est ça chausseur
richmond tout ça je trouve que ça fait
ça se tient tout seul évidemment il ya
le pelage est un vrai problème
existe aussi on n'est pas en train de
banaliser seul mais on n'est pas du tout
demain devant la même heure
même genre de propositions mais celle ci
s'est quand même évident je trouve qu
est-ce qui est
7e et on tarantino qui fait un hommage
au bon exemple aux films sortis au film
de samouraïs japonais évoqué mme claire
mal il ya un amour pour ce cinéma là il
rend hommage qui ont trait que ça paraît
quand c'est fait avec avec respect puis
par amour bien que c'est fait puis de
manière justement à ce petit pas caché
mais vraiment y comme ben c'est comme si
tu en train de me dire moi je suis
arrivé au cinéma
parce qu'il est gay j'ai tellement aimé
et regarder ses films là c'est ça qui
sait axa veut dire le jeu sinon
artistiquement
par un trip d'esthétique qu'il ya peu
intérêt il n'y a pas beaucoup d'intérêt
à faire scintiller beaucoup aidé intérêt
à faire quelque chose que déjà été fait
quasiment
tout ce qui reste c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment la marre je puis dire - c'est
ce qui c'est ce qui m'a amené
surtout qui le fait passer pour son
premier film noté été enlevé à ses
lecteurs on dirait que je veux pas me
comparer du tout mais je constate que
plus les années passent plus je
m'inscris dans cette dynamique là center
de reconnaître celui de l'avant tous
ceux qui étaient là avant moi puis
depuis ce qui me constitue
artistiquement dit souvent ça va au delà
de tout ça parce que c'est un film là
quand tu l'écoutés tettey août avec un
large tout fait ce qu'il sait ce qui se
passait chez vous à la maison fait tout
ça devient un briquet avec le personnel
c'est ce qui est beau dans dans
la musique ont attrapé les films dont
notre pays nous sommes par les goonies
je suis jetée où je sais à quoi je
ressemble et puis
c'est tout tout ça d empreinte forte
dans ta vie féminisé pas pu remarquer je
travaille avec ariane leroy le truc qui
faisait cela sera même avons dit que
j'aime beaucoup puis
ont coréalisé l'album ensemble c'est
qu'ils ont travaillé les toons travaillé
les arrangements puis à l'arrivée avec
une tonne puis on essaye de faire en
arrangements différents styles et le
voyait plus balade au départ plus plus
dépouillé plus on essaie d affaires
dahmani a fait non love finalement c'est
une france quand même bizarre ça serait
quand même pas aux petits qui
chante une ligne de gaieté a dit le
guide pour faire comme un parce que
c'est comme tout au tout tout tout tout
tout tout tout tout tout petit le
freecom ok mais ceci c'est de police le
ccrb titech
je suivais fait à qui on l'espère on
s'inquiète on enregistrait précis comme
acquis c'est vraiment de police mais en
même temps de tout ce qu'on essayait de
loin le meilleur cepici tellement clair
voilà ce que ça va être la clé la toune
en février à va sortir puis c'est comme
un hommage à vue à o'leary fle des
guitares les plus célèbres des sceaux en
mettant le truc esman pour notre idée
week-end a pu se permettre de sonner
comme take on me à ce point là
je me rappelle possible le le bon titre
mais
si je dois tu écoutes et une lola c'est
un c'est un hommage avouez ça est sans
l'ombre d'un doute à
l'énorme tube des années 80
ce vidéo clip de c'est une les deux
clubs de tekken mid je peux si vous
voulez remplacer un croyant est safe
était fait dans ces années-là ccc mieux
fait que des clips qui sont faites
aujourd'hui dans les grands grands clips
de
l'époque où les clés pas enlever la tc
seltz a mis la barre très haute pour
ceux qui n'ont jamais vu aller voir seul
c'est un clip d'animation
dessinée
c'est le fait jour entre la réalité et
la ligue b déplaçait à mener dans bd le
caecum dessinée pédant bd pléiade de
chanteurs qui n'en bd puis ça mix entre
les entrants sert aussi beaucoup
beaucoup aidé à la popularité à mousser
la popularité de l'actrice a participé
aux essais d'abord le refrain qu'avec le
plus la plus grande remontée de
l'histoire démontre mon fils dit un
crash capable de le faire mais nous
mettons en oeuvre
pour puis partout si beau par exemple
c'est ainsi que je sais ce n'est pas si
ce n'est pas d'un
pardessus avec sa voix de jeune garçon
je voulais je voulais me suis dans une
période dans ma vie où est ce que je me
questionne beaucoup sur l'endroit où est
ce que je vive puis pour un gars de
québec rrq la vienne la gaspésie piccolo
est à en estrie
travailleurs de l'oréal
qu'est ce qui a justifié pas justifiée
mais qu'est ce qui t'a amené à aller en
estrie hat est loin d'un centre urbain
alors que toi un métier qui clairement
ne nécessite que tu as souvent dans les
centres urbains - qu'est-ce qui a fait
que en est après la décision faire comme
elle il faut que vous avez pris le
défendrai faut qu'on sorte de de ces
milieux là faut qu'on s'éloigne un peu
ben
je pense que beaucoup de choses qui nous
amène à cette décision là où il y avait
le fait qu'on est vraiment né et ma
blonde et moi dans les milieux ruraux en
gaspésie avec
c'est chez nous la cour avait pas
vraiment de faim parce que le chêne en
arrière un site à mon oncle puis le
boisé aussi fait que ces mots des
limites de terrain ça existe et ça a été
à tort que je comprends c'est
probablement que ça c'est bien
c'est bien imprimé en moitiés poche le
6000 pieds carrés de terrain loges c'est
sûr que ça pourrait pas être joli une
première il ya l'accès à la propriété ça
m'amène à seul aux 6m abandonné 1 nous
on voulait acheter puis le saut je te
parle développe d'année s'était déjà
problématique je voudrais moi je me suis
un travailleur autonome puis mes
affaires marché a vraiment cette époque
lui le non pas du tout bla bla on était
en congé maternité ça veut dire quoi sur
papier ça veut dire sans emploi il ya
aucune différence entre pour les
institutions financières
moi je voulais pas me faire endosser par
mon père j'avais pas envie d'être ça
j'avais 30 ans puis puis je prends
jugement que j'arrête faire là c'est mon
souvenir un mois que
ou qu'est ce qu'on achète pour où on
achète évidemment tout de suite si tu
veux acheter battu sort les centres
urbains
puis ç'a toujours été l'enjeu a toujours
été d'avoir une certaine proximité avec
la ville ou au moins un espace ville
mais de pas y habiter team mais moi j'ai
toujours eu ce rapport-là montréal
mangeant un pied à terre à montréal avec
des colloques mais ça ne s'est jamais
senti que c'était une résidence pour moi
j'habite pas à montréal j'ai jamais
habite à montréal [ __ ] tu habites pas
quelque part
tu restes avec moi je me rappelle quand
j'ai mon premier appartement que mouski
le à 17 ans les premières semaines molle
il ya comme un effet d'étrangeté qui
vient avec la ville
nouveauté il ya quelque chose de
d'excitantes
qui est vraiment trippant puis + tab est
l'endroit ça se transforme ça s'estompe
aussi ça devient autre chose c'est
trippant aussi mais les premiers les
premiers sparkle ils sont plus le hot
six mois avec montréal j'ai tiré au
maximum j'ai quand même je connais de
mieux en mieux montréal mais je découpe
tout le temps plein d'affaires c'est ce
parcours là ils sont encore utiles jean
vit encore et je sais que plus qu'à tab
est une ville sûre ça change par par
expérience fait que ce rapport là que
j'ai avec montréal je te conseille way
puis il c'est parfait comme ça moi je
suis fait pour habiter dans le bois
mais en même temps il faut pas que ce
soit trop loin pas que
l'un plus l'autre les séries ça devenait
intéressant ma soeur habite à sherbrooke
je m'étais fait vanté le coincer c'est
vraiment un beau coin c'est super le
super chouette puis mon chum valia lui
habitait là bas
à l'époque on se connaissait un petit
peu mais puis savais que je cherchais
que j'allais move et puis m'informer sur
sur la grande région de l'estrie qui
m'avait dit c'est moi je j'adore mon set
up c'est vraiment le fun la vibe et trip
hop puis on s'habitue si j'ai déjà moi
pendant un bon bout de temps rouler
lotbinière région de lotbinière car
montréal créé des fois aller retour le
jusqu'à jusqu'à vivre un épisode où les
humains ont fermé sur le nouveau nid au
pij mais monfils n'est juste de naître
et je me rappelle je buvais l'instant la
ds espèce de boissons énergisantes au
café la
grosse quand même j'ai eu un court
épisode où je buvais ça pour me tenir
éveillé c'est un moment lol straubing
stop la facture gg
j'ai ramassé les vibreurs me suis ouvert
les yeux c'est vraiment comme si j'avais
chanté dans un bond de t'endormir sa
durée est évidemment de fraction de
seconde
chaline stationner j'ai braillé ma ville
parce que je pars ce départ pour moi pas
pour les conséquences je me paye le
groupe s'était plaint qu'un enfant
maintenant aussi le j'ai vraiment eu la
chienne puis un style vous me ferez
jamais boire c'est comme être malade à
12 sur l'alcool peut plus jamais jamais
tequila c'est l'odeur de cette affaire
des proches un peu comme os et ça pour
dire que les là les longues robes pas si
longue mais quand même fait trop souvent
au monde année j'en avais subi le pire
fecq se trouvait le sweet spot qui
allait rassembler toutes ces
ces ingrédients leur a fait que ça
m'amène ça va maintenant un strip i
je suis super bien évidemment c'est
encore très attaché à
ma région natale encore beaucoup de
charme d'abord mes parents sont le minot
par aussi fait qu'on y retourne le plus
souvent possible en jetant contre s
attacha gaspésie mais en dehors de la
ville ça tape dessus et
je peux rester grande et sur
l'essentiel éviter les pièges mais
tendaient de la célébrité
de la célébrité non parce que je suppose
c'est quoi les pièges laisser libres les
pièges du work
moi je suis pas très rock puis on
s'éteint c'est un bond de running gag
dans mon bain de souligner tous les ans
démarre à quel point je ne suis pas et
nous sommes pauvres rock puis on attend
plus on est dans la surenchère avec
cette tournée l'eau entre il qu'est ce
que c'est plutôt être bon courage le
mieux moi j'ai il ya de la sobriété d'un
bambin ya des gens qui à un moment donné
dans l'avion arrêté de bois fait que sur
pied on a tous développé un goût pour
les produits sans alcool
dans ce métier là il y à de l'alcool
tout le temps à porter gratuite axa peut
être oui dangereux mais juste aussi
comme tout match up
c'est moi le premier le jeu ici est de
la bière le non-stop et je peux
facilement avoir toujours trop souvent
et puis mais faites au lendemain de la
bière sans alcool ya plus de bière sans
alcool dans notre fredo que fonctionne
déjà c'est pas super rock mais là la
dernière fois l'an on s'est aperçu à
quel point on aime aller manger des
restos mais des fois on aime ça aussi
parlé du lunch pu manger dans la loge je
souhaite rentrer nous fait que la petite
tenons au pire on semaine la bouteille
de vin puissent au pyla j'ai amené juste
pour forger un diffuseur duel 100 passes
mouche vous dites est aussi depuis une
couple d'années il faut pas si longtemps
j'aime beaucoup le thé fait que je
traîne douter avec le tout le monde au
pas triste du tout petit et le gros
regret à l'ecosse d'oranger quoi on
serait passé à sting qui je faisais des
shows avec sa tisane
to work est mort pis la dernière fois
j'ai amené pour la job un diffuseur
d'huiles essentielles
j'écris c'est sur le piano dentaire au
niveau auquel il y avait la petite heure
en secret au sport savez aucun bon sens
qui pourtant qu'un coran sur 5 octobre
avec celle à jo tout ça pour dire que
moi je
j'avoue que je me suis souvent mais fier
de mon âge je suis pas un oiseau de nuit
fait sa soeur scheid pour en fait la
question n'est pas là mais je me suis je
me suis méfié justement de ce2 de ce
rapport à l'alcool ou mind mettent dans
des situations tu sais où j'allais à
devoir prendre des décisions difficiles
je prends mon par rapport à mon cours
par rapport à
comportementale tout ça parce qu'il est
pas j'ai pas plus sain qu'un autre mais
ouais je souvent je me disais
si j'y vais pour ces puits ses
participants beaucoup de disparités sont
plus en gestion avait dit harry potter
ok c'est au-dessus fait pourquoi tu
irais à la base parce que
il ya un certain fait maintenant ça se
trouve tu veux participer à cette femme
le sait c'est quoi ton dû questionner
des motifs le fait d'avoir des enfants
aussi à peu près en même temps que ça
décolle mots si ça a été comme pour
baliser la france a été no brainer
j'peux moi je je disais c'est pas vrai
que je vais aller me saoule ailleurs la
à cet endroit l'appui que ma blonde doit
se lever avec les kids le matin
ben c'est pas comme ça que ça marche le
grain sinon faisant pas des enfants pas
trop
mais tout ça ne peut pas cohabiter
ensemble sur la
question c'est que
je ne connais pas personnellement mais
qui me semble dingue vraiment d un bleu
taroteurs petit avec notamment les
valeurs familiales mais c'est mon
éthique est il aussi aux dents dans le
portrait des personnalités publiques au
québec moi je suis dans la cas de la
catégorie
bongo fils m'a tout les types madame
même pas je serai le gendre idéal c'est
cpie que tu le veuilles ou poster
casting là existent après si ça te fait
chier ou pas - sam des fois ça me fait
chier des fois ça sam parce que on
catégorise vite mais après ça si tu peux
faire ce que tu veux c'est difficile
d'en sortir ou pour les bonnes ou les
mauvaises raisons là mais sauf que
admettons le fou je vais la mettre à la
base ça me définis plutôt bien read and
go qui est smap j'aime travailler que le
monde je suis pas juge pas chien
suis respectueux avec avec les gens avec
les filles avec
ça donne l'impression que mam n'est sûr
que c'est que du positif le dispositif
aujourd'hui maintenant tu es après dix
ans de carrière plus que c'est que tu
étais rendu un non je dirais
tous les foyers du québec ou presque
connaît c'est patrice michaud on essaye
de manière ou d'une autre et puis mais
si tu rentres ici puis jamais qu'on a
senti
que c'était mon tatoo qu'elles étaient
il ya vingt ego puisque ce que je me
marre de justice et comme si c'est un
effort conscient de com
de retourner à l'essentiel du métro ont
piqué ça ça reste comme un peu séparé
les deux étoiles entre les deux je pense
qu'une nature profonde de fait en sorte
que je suis bien outillés pour
passer à travers sur puis rester
relativement humble et moi même mais je
le cache pas il y aussi un travail
conscient sur lego ou le tir je le sens
après les années qui parle de mon ego a
changé puis souvent j'essaie de prendre
une distance puis de regarder ça
objectivement pu faire qu'un joker et eu
des moments où je me trouve tout le
match et tu dis je suis conscient de ça
aux iut des fois quand il y avait des
événements puis c'est pas ça que je
voulais puis des fois je me trouve
princesse dans mon rapport professionnel
à venir avec les gens avec qui je
travaille puis soit je pose la question
si tu
me lis car là je
suis impatient ou c'est où je sais pas
ce que je veux dire où je pensais avoir
délégué quelque chose finalement
il ya un travail aussi sur les groupes à
j'ai pas envie de venir cette personne
du tout du tout du tout s'il en est
conscient au moins c'est le tu peut
prévenir d'avancé comme c'est comme pour
ben des affaires c'est comme c'est comme
le reste mais je pense aussi que
fondamentalement j'ai toujours été comme
ça je suis sur moi
que vous croisez quelqu'un qui m'a connu
au secondaire qui me connus à
l'université qui me connaît aujourd'hui
le
très à l'aise très très à l'aise à ce
que vous puissiez questionner cette
personne ne peut savoir
c'est une façade
c'est drôle toujours pas pourquoi je
pense à ce qu'un
quand on me propose l'animation de stars
à cannes même grosse affaire jeunes est
un extraterrestre qui arrivent
tard et pauvre en place et non dans la
vie normale
pas de pandémie je fais pas ça c'est sûr
sur ce je dis pas qu'il vienne qui qui
me le propose aussi pour moi je pense
que normalement j'aurais pas eu le temps
aussi d'accepter en affaire demande qui
ça m'aurait pas j'arrête je me serais
jamais mis dans un 27 pour accepter sûr
mais là on est dans un moment où il ya
plus personne qui tourne on travaille
pau
puis il ya ce projet nous on te voit la
honte accompagnerez l'appui ça serait
saidal ça fait partie de la nouvelle
identité de l'émission qu'on veut avoir
fait je pense je réfléchi à tout ça je
rencontre les producteurs
j'en parle c'est exactement pendant
la vague du mythe ou un au québec c'est
exactement juge juste un peu après les
grandes sorties qui ont touché beaucoup
de monde dix bambins des go 2 go castle
un faux rythme il a pendant l'été une
personne en parle et qui est plus la fin
on checke voici des questions tout ce
récit qu'est ce que j'ai comme le
sentiment que yang mention rosé m'en
parle
pas c'est moi qui la g de speed by the
wind je sais pas si vous vous posez des
questions sur un quelconque squelettes
dans le placard si vous vous êtes un peu
inquiet parce qu'il ya sont sortis
kingate
on essaie quand même fait depuis vingt
et un ans
ça va aller
j'ai ressenti il se posait pas demandé
mais vraiment tout le monde était là
dedans
c'est sa
chance et maps c'est la partie
le gpat ray winstone a toujours était
belle à apport à part le l'aura du bon
golf rude parce qu'ayant qui ont pensé à
toi de ton sensible et je sais pas je ne
sais pas je pense que
bon en fait je sais pour y
tuer jean philippe jean philippe dion
m'avait vu en spectacle il était venu
voir un mois j'ai fait un show avec leur
caisse symphonique de québec 15 minutes
avec la chope ferme février mars
puis j'ai fait ce show là un peu comme
comme je fais les miens c'est à dire
avec un
narratif
je pense que les messages étaient
peut-être déjà dans les discussions dans
l'est dans l'ailé la liste des
animateurs animatrices potentiel je
pense j'ai bien compris par la suite
qu'ils cherchaient dans le giron de la
musique il est vraiment quelqu'un
issu de la musique qui travaillent
encore au kivu qui a fait ça longtemps
fait que je sais pour je devais remplir
des critères moi j'ai toujours eu cette
aisance l'homme en même temps faire des
choix simon ce que je fais dans vivant
animé cette métaphore à télé un show en
direct dans des conditions wild pas de
public
pendant deux heures à chaque semaine
c'était quand même c'est vraiment
la ferrari après jeu avec ton probatoire
je les ai dit constamment jeudi là vous
êtes conscient que moi j'ai aucune
référence le je sais pas quoi faire ces
jeux d'hier j'ai jamais animé un atelier
j'ai jamais animé en direct évidemment c
un show
attendu outre est une grosse production
de tuer tout le monde évite si
l'histoire est démis assidûment
au temps au temps évidemment je connais
ses seuls je vais même étaient déjà
invitées à la sortie de mon premier
album en 2011 j'étais allé faire un tour
à la dite et la dernière édition le
dernier ramené
social
non puis moi j'ai été très clair avec ça
je veux dire qu'un star academy arrive
moi j'étais à l'université
j'ai un peu de musique jeux très au
dessus de tout ça je suis plutôt
critique par rapport à ça puis
aujourd'hui
jean jean prigent l'est dans le sens où
il ya une
proposition télévisuel c'est qui qui qui
ne met la musique est en avant-plan mais
il n'y a pas juste ça c'est dire il a le
profil des jeunes et un casting là
dedans il ya la vie en communauté les
gens vont s'attacher une proposition qui
y adhèrent aussi à des repos avec son
moi j'aime beaucoup d'eau dans mon vin -
ce que j'animais c'est les spectacles
musicaux et ça ça me parlait comme
beaucoup je n'aurais pas accepté
d'animer un show
si au centre de ce n'était pas de la
musique puis des jeunes motivés et
talentueux qui veulent faire ça n'aurait
pas animé occupation double je réponds à
nîmes et occupation double ben on
a beaucoup qu'un jugement cm
mais c'était quand même un défi colossal
colossal puis j'ai eu dans les plus
grandes craintes et les plus grands
moments d'angoissé professionnels liés à
des épisodes l'autre c'est le propre de
la première émission qui était une des
plus difficiles parce que justement faut
que tu partes la machine
[Musique]
je j'ai en consomme en un appareil dans
l'oreille la fameuse pinottes qui note
lien avec la réalisation
mois
après les premières 45 minutes du show
matinal à auch où j'ai plus rien je suis
à la voile le moko celle puis le
j'essaye je suis comme j'ai l'impression
d'être capitaine d'un paquebot qui sait
pas conduire qu'à part de l'eau plutôt
que sont les moteurs ont lâché
l'école pour aller aux publicités les
bamber les retours j'ai crié j'ai fui
gfr hier deux bonhommes en touche qu'un
pur jeu et puis ils vont bien s'en rende
compte que je suis papa que si 19h dans
l'oreille
après six arrivées d'un fois c'est
arrivé deux fois durant 16 ans et puis
là je vous en parle parce qu'il ya eu
des événements comme ça mais il ya quand
même eu des tirs je suis super content
d'avoir fait ça je suis fier de moi sa
peau était une catastrophe qu'ont
que j'ai été révélé comme un grand
animateur mais je pense que dans le
contexte j'ai vraiment fait la job je
suis plutôt fier de moi pis
style est fait c'est un jeu les répéter
souvent mais écoute c'est vrai
c'est un privilège d'essayer des
affaires qui n'a jamais fait c'est aussi
l'occasion de trop sérieux moi je
préfère me casse la gueule que de rester
dans les abris et puis j'ai un certain
parties de ma personne qui plutôt les et
bruit
c'est important de me donner les
impulsions car quand il faut sauter
comme neige mais on vivait une période
improbable d'où une décision est probant
mais il y a j'ai vraiment fait un truc
ninja durant la saison que personne n'a
vu à la maison mais j'ai vraiment j'ai
sauvé la mise pour en parler à louis
sclavis qui a système soe évidemment
rien au fait on pas un numéro musical
avec tout les jeunes qui sont encore là
puis c'est ariane qu'il y soit parce que
c'est une tombe qui ont composé
à wattrelos durable durant les sessions
durant la semaine
fait que on parle atone puis j ai
peut-être trente secondes de passer puis
là je vois je vois rien ne bouge sur la
tonne absolument je suis jamais en poche
je suis parti c'est assez peu de moments
musicaux à part les miens lourd dans la
fin mais la drôle de hasard je suis
l'homme joue des fruits en plastique
deux reprises d'abord
attaqué qui a mené je vois ariane allait
vraiment le chevreuil l'autoroute il ya
quelque chose si vos repas puis je sens
une certaine panique comme année je le
vois son pack qui relié à ses aînés
alors chez piétons bâtard fait et elle a
le besoin petit c'est injuste un medley
avec des comptes sont déjà dans l'ordi
avec il ya du temps claude là dessus
c'est elle qui lie de la patente alors
plus rien aucune référence aucun cas
aucun kong sont déjà dans le tango fait
que ak pas de ben ripley maniche caps je
regarde luis pilou et ce comme vu ça
aussi mais louis s'y joue
j'ai fait tout et la soeur et elle seule
qui ait des fruits dans les jeux je suis
libre de mes mouvements je me dis j'ai
confiance dans l'équipe ils vont
découper s'il me voit partir ils vont
les y vivent ont passé ils vont ils vont
se dire qu'est ce qu'il fait là luc à
lys qui vont aller chercher d'ordinaire
je pars je m'en vais me cacher à côtés
d'ariane en live tv l'autre si je
ramasse son pack jir branche qui
consiste en dessous de la fesse mais
solide parce qu'il est en jeu il ya
nulle part watchmouse qui avait accroché
sommeil avait pas fait le fameux de 3
autour de fil autour du pack fait que
j'y consens dessus de la faire ce que je
fais là me regarde avec des cartes
vierges en couleur au crayon délivrance
l'aja revient je rame ans me free
finisseur merci bonjour et on se voit en
prêt n'a pas ou c'est moi qui fais le
terrain on s'en va à pause luis clavis
mari vient boire ici
si c'est pour ça qu'il fallait musiciens
lendemain sur sa star ac à des revues et
c'est ce qui s'est passé depuis leurs
branches et
ses traits fermés - c'est tous des
petites affaires sous terre la présence
mais beaucoup de beaux souvenirs
beaucoup d'apprentissage
et
un esprit d'équipé
hallucinant même si c'est une grosse
prod l'emprise de rast un personnel non
non non je versais c'était fou de faire
ce show dans le contexte qu'on vivait à
ce moment là c'était super compliqué on
changeait beaucoup de choses à dernières
minutes tout était comme
à 4 secondes de tomber à l'eau au pied
ça a été vraiment leur île des bottes
mais la faute à personne juste est
immense pipi mois travers tout ce qui
devait comme apprendre un nouveau métier
ça super cool suis pas je l'écouté sur
tous les dimanches en fait le tpiy
je trouve ça fait super je m'adresse
j'avais des idées des maladresses ou des
moments de live c'est
tellement
naturel puis toi même qui est testée
comme pardonner ouais ça seulement
thierry sujet de récupérer
l'échappée gasset c'est l'avis de ses
médecins
tout ça passerait encore mieux avec du
public amateur 3 réactions du public
vous allez les les saisons précédentes
de star académie lotis ont réécouté seul
le public c'est over de top je veux dire
c'est
les réactions du public dans des gros
shows comme ça c'est over placé
numéro 2 croirait quasiment que c'est
quelqu'un
à l'abri avec un fait d'un public qui
verra
vraiment avec des animateurs de foule
puis des fois tu le tiens c'est
quasiment sûr que c'était tout le
contraire fait mouche content ça a
ramené évidemment on en aurait pris un
peu si on avait pu nous si on avez mais
c'est sa
carte chez pas une affaire aussi sur la
production télévisuelle puis
je connaissais pas complet c'est
vraiment un monde vraiment liste est
rafraîchissant d'avoir quelque chose de
gpotato hors ajustement plus plus un peu
plus sobre plus terre-à-terre hendrix t
comme plus naturelle entre sdf ça
faisait du bien dans celle ci on l'a
d'abord d'avoir ce plutôt quelque chose
de tout bois mais je pense ça m'a servi
puis ça fait aussi en sorte que ces
personnes l'attendaient kendrick
infernale c'est un auteur compositeur
interprète
je pense que ça s'est su assez vite que
les personnes qui a senti qu'il entraîne
le magazine et une job d'animation atv
j'ai accepté quelque chose une
proposition des filles appelle ça comme
tu veux puis
je pense que dans mon rapport avec les
jeunes aussi le qui allait peut-être
au-delà de l'animateur m aux jo j'ai
accompagné tout le long
je les filets dans tout le choix tourner
je te le répète
j'en ai fait chanter de son album
absolument puis sais pas c'était pas
pour
cesser pas écrit derrière featuring
chayan et rosalie de star académie
leçons d'un freddy dans le livre en
dedans parce que c'est des choristes je
vous laisse et j'avais besoin de citer
voilà je dis moi je vous engage comme
l'uci parce que ce que vous faites ça me
touche jouée sur la méthode on n'est pas
en train de se la jouer
je ne peux pas tabler samir annabi était
super content parce que c'est une guide
de musée la musique j'ai engagé comme
musicien d'accueil à tout ça puis
non c'est très chouette je m'en rappeler
longtemps etc si comme un moment de ma
vie on parle et
je m'en voudrais te laisser partir avant
de ramener la conversation qu'on avait
au début avant de tourner sur ta
nouvelle passion quand je suis arrivé je
mettais dans la rue que je me dis je me
dis c'est le genre la fois qu'ils
évitent et des autres sans fil des fois
on essaie de le rencontrer toutes les
personnes derrière leur derrière le nom
de l'image 38 puis là on fait bien sûr
depuis tantôt le métier de savoir
maintenant je sûr qu'il ya plein de
monde qui écoutent amusé qui n'ont
qu'une idée du monde qui tripent sur
donjons dragons de voir une idée que
c'est une passion voilà il y en a qui le
savent parce que je mange je me suis
jamais gêné d'en parler mais c'est rare
qu'on pose direction l'addition mais
j'en ai déjà parlé parce que j'ai
toujours
j'ai toujours assumé le fait qu'il ya un
pour moi un lien certain entre
donjons dragons et le fait que je fasse
ce métier là aujourd'hui parce que moi
avant l'âge de 13 ans je lis à peu près
rien je faisais jouer au baseball dans
le champ arrière hsbc que chez terra et
un moment donné on découvre sur mon
premier coup d'oeil on découvre ça le
jeu de rôle donjons dragons et on capote
je me mets à lire les manuels moi je
jouais à la deuxième édition qui venait
de sortir c'est baky
j'hésite toujours d'ailleurs et c'est le
premier livre que j'ai lu j'ai dévoré ça
et puis le jeu développé un intérêt pour
ce genre d'univers l'ofac - 12 13 14 ans
l'heroic fantasy
j'en ai lu mais je dire tout à passer au
battre loto calais belle grillade
michael moorcock j'en ai lu jeunes élus
j'en ai lu d'après sur la science
fiction l'horreur toutes les preuves
tout les hommes la littérature de genre
assez le policier mais ça a l'air plus
plus tard et puis et puis après ça les
livres en soit la littérature en soit
mon amour pour les livres et intimement
reliés aux jeux de rôle et je sais
pertinemment que j'aurais jamais écrit
eu envie d'écrire ou cautionné
me donner comme l'autorisation d'écrire
si j'avais pas d'abord beaucoup lui fait
qu il ya une ligne en ligne qui est
rassurant et 2 et puis
depuis quelques mois
j'ai vraiment jeu j'ai toujours joué
comme une gaine par 2 3 1 avec les amis
de les amis de l'époque mon maître deux
enjeux de l'époque mon grand ami
philippe qu'habitant gaspésie français
c'est lui qui nous avait introduit à
ceux ci nous l'archétype du joueur de
donjons dragons savait pas c'est quoi on
découvrait quelque chose que je me
rendais à leur faire découvrir découvrir
ce sans aucun sens aucune conception ray
conception préjugé aucun préjugé st t'es
pas obligé d'avoir les cheveux longs
cette époque là c'était ma vie c'est ce
qu'à cette époque là c'était très les
arts les archétypes de joueurs de
donjons dragons étaient c'était flagrant
c'est bien mais vraiment j'ai su après
en changeant de ville parce qu'en
gaspésie ne sont pas sourds il y avait à
peu près personne qui jouait assure dans
mon coin mais tu sais quand j'arrive au
cégep de rimouski puis la première
journée j'ai comme croisé le local de
jeu de rôle de jéhovah la porte puis
j'ai vu vraiment là
dgo enculeurs de jogging les cheveux un
peu gras que j'en mets un peu
probablement dans mon souvenir s'est
déformée m mangin gattuso à 12 heures du
mans durant l'après-midi et
avoir un filtre actif match qui va
fermer la porte
c'est une époque où c'était quand même
très justement sa sacoche chacun sa cage
le geek donjons dragons étaient vraiment
complètement cours d accrocher
et pilar avec les années puis les puis
le jeu que je recommence à m'intéresser
à ce je constate que
j'ai toujours aimé cd souvenir hyper
précieux que j'aurais probablement du
plaisir à rejouer à ça puis là je
découpe des podcasts pour pas les nommer
coup critique et hugues un nez des gangs
pilote mélasse et décomplexée c'est
démocratique
tout le monde sait il ya plus les
jugements de valeur un candidat fc super
inclusif ça a été mais coville proof là
je veux dire il ya vraiment
il ya un regain d'intérêt pour les peaux
les jeux de rôles qui sont qui démarrait
donc une couple d'années que ce que je
suis ce que j'entends puisque je
constate apic été exacerbée par le
pendant la pandémie tout le monde jouait
à distance mais ensemble d'idées comme
vraiment le fun moi j'écoute surtout
super nostalgique je suis pilote je me
rends compte que je suis moi-même un
archétype dans la catégorie des godes 40
ans avec des enfants nation jouer du
rock était adolescent et qu'il up en
bulles puis prennent conscience qu'ils
aiment encore sûr on est plusieurs ce
constat-là on immobilière qui
écoutent j'écoute je tripe je leur
achète des livres et je suis même en
train de moi je suis pas maître de jeu
je mange et un ancien joueur mais
pour faire plaisir à mon ancien mon
maître de jeu un jour on va le dire
encore ce qui est des grands amis
finalement je tenterai nothing in a way
j'étais en train d'écrire un scénario en
même temps je me complais pas trop
l'esprit le jeu dire je ramasse un peu
strangers tings beaucoup de l'offre
crafts un peu de citron y passent une
série qui sera pragmatisme et kiala
c'est un jeu de rôle puis fait que j'ai
acheter les livres les règles sont super
sympas je brasse tout seul avec du
midnight mass de netflix avec un truc
bien dégueulasse bien d'un gâteau aussi
je vais faire jouer ça pendant le temps
des fêtes et les parkings
c'est c'est vraiment un
il ya vraiment rapport nostalgique là
dedans un rapport avec avec tout mon
amour de la littérature et beaucoup
d'affaires dans cette souffle qui
j'écoute des gens passionnés de sa pige
très belle pour ceux qui nous écoutent
coup critique et on les salue d'ailleurs
six mois puis j'ai si vous voulez vous
trempez un petit peu dans l'univers j'ai
participé moi même à un one shot avec ce
qu'on parle
j'ai tripé raid mois l'année passée
j'ai monté une game pour pour une gang
d'amis puis pourrait justement à l'ipad
chaque semaine ils ont joué une fois par
semaine sur sept tableaux dans notre
local est ce qu'on est en personne puis
juste avant que la pandémie tombe car la
pandémie est arrivé on sait on a arrêté
un peu plus tard sous sont encore la
bonne
humeur au téléphone
pour catherine importe c'est tout il ya
tout là dedans je pense je pense aux
parents le tir avec des enfants qui qui
grandit sous qui c'est qui qui qui
ramène sa maison qui s'intéressent là je
veux dire là dedans il ya de l'esprit
d'équipé il ya du jeu entre amis oui
seront pas en train de jouer au soccer
ou de faire du basket lot mais ils sont
pas derrière un écran nous allons la
jouer à 18 ans il a d'ailleurs dû
théâtre il ya de l'improvisation il ya
de l'érudition il faut que tu aies
courrier de la compréhension du jeu mais
c'est surtout c'est la quintessence du
collaboratif exact c'est la quintessence
du jeu call of viactive de tout le monde
ensemble c'est de raconter la même
histoire passée exact c'est incroyable
de pouvoir écrire une histoire en
gagnent loi avec des amis c'est à la
base de merveilleux souvenirs et
d'amitié
très importantes qui sont encore
précieuse aujourd'hui dans ma vie c'est
bon c'est drôle les archétypes quand
même s'il est justement l'espèce de deux
cases dans lesquelles connaissaient des
classes et les gens le tipi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
déconstruit mais vraiment plus de plus
en plus utile quand on était jeune
témoin je me suis aux primates écouter
du rap teinté de punk de
piscines dites nous au secondaire on
était
[Musique]
mais c'est à la presse par et cdh ont
été les sportifs et puis on était enfant
petit effectif on avait comme l'image de
ce qu'est un autre important la sortie
oui mais on trompé sur le métal ce titre
métal prog métal le médiéval un peu puis
on joue aux cartes magic qui ont été
vraiment à guy conjoints ont joué et ils
ont
finalement dit nous intéresse c'est anti
fièvre tellement plus à ce
qu'ils qualifient y mettons à l'époque
apprenait qu on joue aux cartes
manille altéa place laurier on est à
place laurier à québec je vois
exactement
j'habitais leur rappeler il y avait la
boutique l'imaginaire devant lui
marginal et samedi matin il y avait les
ternois il y avait des tables du tournoi
rappelle comme si c'était hier de se
croiser pinault a installé une couple de
fois participer au tour de moustache
malkin
et les
41 années encore on était des plus
jeunes qui étaient le plongerait on n'a
fait que les gars étaient ont participé
plat m'amener on n'est pas loin si l'on
n'est pas en train de jouer puis l'on
croise des filles de secondaire métiers
qui sont dans la gamme bic ou la gamme
des outils sortait de la boutique à côté
de gilles abry dans le fond le noir
c'est ce pilon les voies pour les
visions
plomb les voyais ne voit pas la vie
viennent ils voient un salut ligue 1
cette table nos radars on est comme ça
un peu aculé
c'est comme l'indiquent les tic les gars
qui jouent plus que moi
c'est comme les attentes qui passe pas
on est joué ça se fasse le tour
mais je
pense que ça serait utopique de dire que
ça existe plus évidemment mais
ça c'est vraiment ça c'est vraiment
dommage mais elle doit maintenant de
triper sur plusieurs sites
c'est comme si c'est moins c'est moins
d'enfants de dentelle germann l'audience
c'est moins 3 années - dieu merci c'est
aussi de savoir je sais pas monsieur
n'était qu'un jouet donjons dragons le
savoir que patrice michaud il joua
donjons dragons mais tant que ça
m'aurait enlevé cette espèce de 10 des
lacs et c'est l'info je fasse dans les
recoins chez pépé qu'il faut pas trop en
parler quand j'arrive au cégep c'est
comme un homme et un enfant on sent que
c'est la même affaire que les groupes et
les filles qui jouent pour car une fois
une fois par semaine c'est là c'est cela
je dire ça tient quasiment du club
social apprécié de l'activité ali quand
on aime le jeu mais
c'est la ligne l'important c'est la
réunion moi je m'ennuie c'est de ça que
je m'ennuie le plus puis en même temps
tant qu'à se réuniront à 66 par la fois
que vous les dd c'est quelque chose qui
me
c'est un c'est vraiment rebirth dans mon
cas au niveau de l'intérêt que les
souvenirs tout revenu du gie ressorti
mes vieux livres j'achète des trucs puis
sous sol phone et j'ai autant de plaisir
c'est moi j'ai jamais joué à des jeux
vidéo mais vraiment jamais mais je donne
aux gosses en garde sur le divan qui
regarde le jeu qui très positif juste
d'écouter écouter du monde passionné de
quelque chose souvent le sujet après
m'importe plein ce qui ce que j'aime
aussi du monde à lui mais qui parle de
ce qu'il est ce que les fait triper
sommes moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
ce après puis
et aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup plus de
forteresse qui en avait avant c'est
le jugement des autres ça c'est vraiment
les gens ils font un peu plus ce qu'ils
veulent dans leurs habits dans leurs
habitudes ça c'est vraiment une bonne
nouvelle j'avais une date en question le
thé on vient de découvrir ton côté geek
donjons dragons de saint puy quand on
écoute ton album on voit aussi que
le gui qui est en toi ils tous
intéressée par l'exploration spatiale
puis tout ce qui est ce parce
que je parlais tantôt que c'est le plus
proche c'est l'album le plus proche d'un
album concept que g20 tient beaucoup à
ce mois ont été de référence à l'accord
séguin justement dans dans le titre le
1.2 le par -1 point bleus
parker qui comme les disques les qu'on a
envoyé dans l'espace en disant peut-être
quelqu'un tombe et là dessus j'ai même
mis la phrase un peu sur l'acide de la
révolution des sphères dans la chanson
un quart de baleine bleue et de la
révolution des sphères c'est le premier
ouvrage de copernic la fête il c'est un
ouvrage de copernic c'est celle ouvrage
en l'aidant dans lequel pour la première
fois quelqu'un pose la question pose
l'hypothèse
je pense que nous ne serions pas le
centre d'un univers qui tourne autour de
nous mais plutôt peut-être plutôt qu on
ait l'infime partie d'un tout qui
tournant autour d'autres shows il ya
manque est brûlée pour émettre une mini
comme ça qui est une réflexion
tout à fait contemporaine quand on y
pense mais qui est qu'ils déclinaient
dans plusieurs de mes tonnes ou stoops
pose des questions existentielles sur
qui est ce que je suis dans ce monde-là
par rapport aux autres c est ce que est
ce que ça tourne autour de moi je
gravite autour de quelque chose de plus
grande c'est mais bon tu vois sa voix
jusque là je ne mets pas mon trip
astro spatiale dans dans cet album la
gelée pas de couper mais c'est pour te
dire j'ai vraiment
j'ai vraiment trippé sur
ses pattes en sueur sur l'événement en
soi que cela la portée
significative
je vais on envoie en 77 une sonde deux
enfants voyagent à un les deux
qui ont pour mission de jamais revenir
d'aller plus loin possible et qui
contiennent une carte postale assez
complète de nous à l'époque et puisqu'on
est de quoi qu'on en dise ça on grave
tout seul on met ça dans le compartiment
grave sur le gros de nos écrits en
anglais sur steam ne se passent pas
leurs beats spatiale de telsa des vies
par lot ses calculs tout seul soit
ramassée france dames c'est passionnant
soi mais moi c'est l'idée derrière ça
c'est
quelque chose il ya quelque chose due
c'est l'ultime
il ya quelqu'un
samo same par la bouteille à la mer doit
on aller financer la bouteille à la mer
absolute un qui est encore en cours soit
dit en passant 22 milliards de
kilomètres à peu près mais arrivait
encore non j'en avais marre c'est parce
que le but n'étant pas d'arrivée ne le
parle
c'est pour casser des pistes de
réflexion vraiment trippant que tu peux
qui peut toucher aux métaux physique et
à la quête existentielle mais qui peut
s'appliquer aussi sur le plancher des
vaches la chanson 1977 et la chanson où
se croisent les deux grands axes de mon
album c'est à dire cet événement-là et
quatre jours plus tard après l'envoi de
la sonde dont les rendu le 9 septembre
mes parents se marient saygnasone même
mes parents se marient et savoir
potentiellement aboutir sur quelque
chose qui ressemble à moi et puis si tu
croises les deux sachs à peu près tout
les toons ce dépôt si c'est sur ce point
sur la carre espèce de dualité entre eux
extrêmement précis orateurs pis le plus
grand que soit examinée la première fois
qu'on pense que qu'on constate que tout
ceci rejoint constamment
c'est ça c'est les grandes questions
existentielles puis du quotidien que
j'essaye de tracy du mieux que je peux
pousser vraiment c'est vraiment la
couleur de
de ce grand voyage d organiser
merci c'est gentil membres merci
beaucoup d'avoir fait un plaisir les g
avait beaucoup aimé ce travail chouette
il souligné quand vous les orphelins
ddc du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante de pétion vous
abonner pour trop de leur part montrés
trop de longs mois et trois pièces par
mois l'as par mois ils avaient les
pattes carte en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis avoir
quitté les podcasts puisse avoir pouvoir
avoir une avance quand vous allez tirer
la dynamique entre les amis sultan avons
une avance sur les jobs en avance les
gens autour de toi mais avec pétillante
une avance sur l'humanité complète en
plus en plus parce que le chèque le
podcast unis voulaient nous en jazz ou
davantage on fait des encore moins de
filtres après chaque pas de castaic là
on vient de finir de tourner le podcast
on vend jaser on va être pile et nicole
non nicoli pleut maintenant comme un
fils travaille à plat ce détail est là
mais on jase on parle de conversion
qu'on m'aide à voir mais ce si vous
voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous s'est excusé
sur pétillant il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous